e
here
oh
e
okay the time being
10:05 G to open the public hearing on HB
650 and we'll intro we'll welcome up Dan
Maguire who was already sitting in his
seat thank you very much Mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
my name is Dan Maguire I represent the
town of Epsom and uh I've had the
privilege for the last two years to be
the chair of a committee called The
Joint Committee on dedicated funds and
among our members is you yourself Mr
chairman and your ranking member behind
me here and um this is a really
interesting committee where uh basically
we we um review all the dedicated funds
that the state has on a five-year cycle
so um every every year we look at 20% of
the dedicated funds we look at how much
is in the funds what's the law behind
them um has anything changed are they
getting too big too small that sort of
thing and so it's it's mostly just sort
of administrative uh kind of stuff but
but it is interesting and you and you
get to learn a lot about sort of the
behind the scenes stuff in state
government the sort of off the books
kind of stuff and things like that and
so one thing we do every year is um of
the funds that we examine we look for
changes that the law needs to make them
current and to and to make them uh
continue to work and so this is this is
a this year we created two bills one is
the one that you yourself sponsored um
dealing with um the cleanup of of RSA 6
colon 12 and all the the lists of funds
and so on but this bill is sort of the
the remaining uh cleanup it's it's not
quite technical corrections but it's you
know the next closest thing um and so
the things we identified this year as
needing
change um one is there were two
dedicated funds that were still in the
RSA 6 colon 12 list but their Associated
law had already been repealed so that's
the two repeals in section five of this
bill uh one other one was the robotics
fund so the legislature has been given
um robotics education about
$750,000 a year that goes into a
dedicated fund and that dedicated fund
goes to high schools it gives grants to
high schools for for robotics activities
and um that fund was sort of
growing you know they weren't using the
full 700 50,000 they were using less and
so one thing we recommend is that we put
a cap on the fund of a million dollars
to uh and and the rest would go back to
the general fund if if there's an excess
and um the way we came up with the
million dollars uh was basically Senator
Gray's um suggestion because it it
removes any problems with timing right
so if the money from the general fund
goes into the fund at any particular
time in the year and money comes out at
some other time during the year the fund
will always have enough so that there's
never a timing issue right so so that's
the that's where that comes from and the
other one that we found was this um
Canon Mount the the parks fund so it
turns out that the parks
department um they have one giant
dedicated fund that they sort of run
their whole department on and and they
kept two separate um accounts within
that fund one for the winter activities
at the Canon Mountain ski area and one
for everything else in the Parks right
and so it just seemed like this this
dedicated fund was kind of overused and
and so this this language will create
two an extra another dedicated fund
specifically for the Canam Mountain
winter activities and to keep it
separate from the rest of what's going
on in the Parks it doesn't really change
how they operate it's just more of an
accounting thing where it'll be easier
to see the two different activities
separately and I'm happy to answer any
questions representative y uh thank you
for taking my question representing
Maguire um first of all online
is that a uh typographical error rather
than $1 billion that's $1
million under the American uh numbering
system that is the last comma should be
a
period well there's the word and right
so I personally don't like commas before
and but it's it seems like it's um
that's a scrier error
yeah we we'll accept it as that uh
another question Mr chair go ahead uh
would you consider this to be a
housekeeping type of a bill to clean up
some
messes like I said thank you for the
question but like I said earlier it's
it's maybe just this side of
housekeeping right because the robotics
thing you can't think of as housekeeping
it's a it's an actual policy kind of
thing but but it's pretty close to that
yes and one last question and would you
have any objection if this bill were
exec today uh
no thank you sir thank
you any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you Mr chairman my committee is meeting
so I'm going to have to leave thank you
for coming before and I hope you get us
uh house resolution what is it 11 ASAP
you you'll get it
soon uh before I before I bring up the
next uh guest I I'll I was remiss in
introducing my wife who was sitting in
sure this this is her first time in the
Legislative Office Building um despite
that I've been a state rep for well I'm
going to my fifth term she has been at
the state house and she has been at
house session um before but I wanted to
welcome her and introduce her to
everyone so round of applause to our
to thank you all right I'll now um bring
Aly official uh
uh suseli city of
Lebanon on I wanted to follow up a
little bit on this uh represent Maguire
had told me that I needed to present it
because he couldn't come so I'm glad he
was able to be here
um there there is a policy issue in the
state parks fund uh but it it really is
a cleanup also the state parks fund uh
was these two groups uh the all the
activities not just winter of the Winter
Ski Area including the
Tramway uh and then every other Park in
the
system and every other Park in the
system has have been having a great
amount of difficulty in raising funds
um the uh historic
houses I can't remember exactly what
it's called but the historic
houses uh
maintenance fund um because they can do
visitor
chores and they put it all in one bucket
and the rest of the
parks are um we'll have a a uh donation
box out somewhere that people can put
money in but that's that's it and it
goes to that particular Park rather than
to all of them so they're having
maintenance problems but it this at
least makes the problem more obvious and
hopefully uh something can be done about
that and I wanted just for the people
who uh were're here with nor major who
know that he started the
robotics
fund um I've talked with him I explained
to him why we're doing this uh it is it
was set up so that it was only to
establish robotics teams in different
schools they seem to be running out of
schools that are capable of doing that
or interested in doing that so um we've
cut back the amount of money in there it
can be increased again if all of a
sudden the really small schools can do
the same thing or something like that so
uh that's what's going on with that he
understands that so um that's all I
really wanted to add to this okay thank
you does anyone have any questions for
ol m Madam ranking member do you have
today microphone microphone I'd like to
point out we scheduled this for next
week by mistake as well so yes and that
and that will be corrected um we we are
not going to have another public hearing
and another
representative okay I'm going to close
Mr
chair since
yes what would it be appropriate to move
into executive commy since we have 15
minutes for the next meeting it would be
very appropriate and since we have
noticed that we can go into exec session
at any time during the day um I am going
see representative
uh Aly would you like to make a motion
yes I move that we uh move I move out to
second second from representative
elberger um would you like to speak to
your motion um I think that um we said
what we need to say but it
um and the title says pretty much what
we need to say remove it removes
references to already repealed funds and
um it separates the two state parks
funds
into um the Canan Mountain ski area fund
and the the um uh rest of the state
parks as a separate fund and
um
on
takes removes the uh non-aps status of
the robotics education funds but allows
up to a million to accumulate in that
fund uh before
lapsing the
remainder thank you any other
discussion yes thank you Mr chair now I
just want to say I appreciate the work
um that the committee does and it is
important thank you anybody
else it is also fascinating
sometimes okay seeing seeing no more
questions or comments um I'm going to
ask the clerk to call the
role thank you m thank you Mr chairman
we are voting on House Bill number 650
FN removing references to repealed funds
and relative to State Park and Robotics
education funds the motion is ought to
pass representative alry
I representative duet yes clerk votes
yes representative soti yes
representative
ores not present Steven Smith not
present representative Tierney yes
representative
Brier ni thank
you representative Ford yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Aly yes representative Southworth yes
representative Malloy yes representative
shamberg yes representative Bolton yes
representative elberger yes
representative Jeffrey
Smith not here representative
op almost I it's getting closer work
working
process representative
yes I I count the vote wait a minute you
haven't called on me
yet the
Jan chairman janigan and with his wife
said clerk counts 16 in favor zero
opposed for missing
Mr chair question yes um recent
instructions were received that a fiscal
note which doesn't raise but merely re
uh abortions monies does not need to go
before the body you can go on consent is
that correct I believe that's
true okay then the vote being 16 to Zer
I uh would put this on consent um
barring no
objections seeing no objections this
will go on the consent calendar um and I
will
close the executive session for
hb650 majority report by uh majority of
report um by representative
elme yes
okay
okay the time being uh 10:21 our next
public hearing doesn't start till 10:30
1s
I mean we're in good enough shape we
650 I'm a little worried
about
uh
yeah
that's
know right that's a
risk drive a motorcycle I never worry
about
everybody
okay so this is this is 650
Bill
okay remember reading police reports
about
accidents
e
there it goes on I am opening the
hearing on House Bill 585 relative to
the property tax exemption for religious
organizations and I call on the prime
sponsor represent janigian to uh
present thank
you oh didn't get that it's interesting
being on this side of the
uh the desk but um anyways U you all
know who I am but for the record I'm
representative John janigian
representing Rockingham District 25
which is
Salem HP 585 is attempting to solve a
problem for small churches and small
religious
organizations uh if you look at RSA
7223 paragraph 3 it lists what
properties exempt from property taxes
and one of the things that is exempt is
a church
parsonage um and for example it's but
it's only tax exempt if the pastor lives
in that parsonage and um however if it's
rented out then it now potentially
subject to the local property tax so I'm
going to give you a real life example um
and you all have a copy of my testimony
now my church is is the arat Armenian
congregation Church in Salem New
Hampshire it's one of many small
churches in the town of
Salem um and we used to have a full-time
Pastor that lived in the parsonage
building um and it's a it's a the
parsonage was a three-bedroom house and
it was detached from the church but but
right next door and as our congregation
became smaller uh we eventually could
not afford a full-time pastor and went
on to having a part-time Pastor who was
living in his own house so so now we're
not using the parsonage anymore the
assessor became aware of that and
started taxing that property and while
it's not necessarily taxed at full
valuation we are paying roughly $4,000 a
year so um it's kind of a double whammy
as we're as we're membership has has
gotten smaller um we we also now have to
pay a property tax so many small
churches are facing this same scenario
and um and that's really impetus to this
bill um I want to point out that um the
bill also allows a church to rent out
space in their main worship building to
raise money for um Church operations or
church Outreach um when it's rented to
other religious organizations it's not
an issue um there's no potential
property tax implication however um if
you rent it out in the example I give
the testimony as you rent it out to a
daycare now that potentially could
trigger the assessor to say okay we have
to partially tax uh this property now
because you're it's not just religious
purposes so what this bill tries to do
is it's it in an attempt not to just
have it does two things in an attempt
not to have churches just start um you
know renting out all sorts of buildings
and making money off them that money has
to be used for paying the pastor church
maintenance or uh standard Church uh
programs and I'm using the word church
but this bill is written in a way to
cover U you know synagogues mosques you
know other religious organizations my
example is a church but you'll see if
you look at the context of the bill it
covers um different religions as well
and um and the other thing it does is it
tries to eliminate so if it's a large
religious organization that has many may
have many parentage may have many
buildings they can't just start renting
them all out to whoever and and and and
taking that money for anything it's
limited to one parsonage and one main CH
worship building that way not giving
large organization's ability to to go
wild with this it limits it but it helps
small organizations as well so um with
questions r your microphone sorry any
questions representative
opal thank you madam chairman sounds
sounds good to say that um and and thank
you representative um we had a similar
situation in in Canan and I'm I'm
wondering in in the case of this church
they were renting or they they were
using the parsonage for their music
director um as opposed to the the pastor
who had had his own home um and the
assessor suggested that that was
contrary to the RSA and they should be
should be taxed I'm I'm wondering is
there any definition anywhere in the
statutes that defines standard
religious um it
programs um I'm not sure but that
phraseology was is used um
I'd have to check but I believe that
phraseology was is used somewhere else
in the statutes and that that's why we
used it um that's why the the drafting
attorney used it follow up just I I'm
just um just to avoid situations like
your own and and the the one we faced in
Canan I'm just I'm just admit perhaps
there's um maybe we could do some
research on this I I would support this
bill absolutely but I'm wondering if
there's if not language in the rsas if
there's Court precedent or something
that um legislative Services
could yes I that's a good point I I I
agree with you we should make sure that
it's solid because we're using that
phraseology we we don't want it to be
open to interpretation that can throw it
off well and I get I'm
sorry based on the situation in Kanan
where the assessor was saying having the
musical director living in the parsonage
was somehow not standard Rel you know
what I think I'm stuck here until we
have so I just thank you for that yeah I
mean actually now that you just said it
that way regardless of of this the the
fact that it somebody other than the
pastor can be in there would actually
cover that so I think I think in that
covered any other
questions um
repr thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question question actually
two one is a technical question and that
is is there a fiscal note anywhere
attached to this do we have any idea of
fiscal impact it there should be no
fiscal impact because this is Town Town
taxation okay thank you and a separate
question the in lines 5 six and seven
you talk about regularly recognized and
constitu constituted
denomination there are lots of very
large religious organizations and there
are also some really tiny ones who does
the recognizing I mean if I wanted to
open and I'm going to deliberately be
silly here if I wanted to open up a
church uh to worship the oak tree in my
backyard and I got 20 people to say that
sounds like a great idea I mean just how
are we
defining or who is defining what a
regularly
recognized that's a good question I I
don't know who's defining it but at the
same
time you know going down that same
example you could potentially try to get
a a tax exemption for that and so
whatever governs that sort of situation
would would kind of be the same okay
thank
thing
representative or thank you madam chair
can I can I just say I'm so used to
orang so I don't know if you have any
experience with this but having been an
elder in the church uh we had to present
like a uh the
bulletin a list of the itinerary what
what the church functions were so I
would assume as a an ongoing Church
Fellowship you have those sort of things
and I think by federal
law that's what's going to determine
whether or not you're an ongoing
actually functioning church is that
something do you have any idea
recollection of that or well we we do
have uh Church bylaws that Define how
the church operates what its structure
is and uh what its Duties are in each in
each area yeah because I believe Federal
you represent Balon
thank you madam chair um regarding uh a
GU Salem's due diligence on how they
determined that part of the property was
um Revenue making and did the assessor
periodically just you know come by and
different conditions for the church and
the the parsonage I mean how was it
discovered did you report
or that's that's a good question I I
don't remember uh we've been actually
paying
this um it's been it's been years um and
what triggered what triggered this was
and I think um one of the people
testifying later is going to talk to is
um that last year the assessor uh and
and assessors from several towns started
um assessing Church property um because
they were making and I'm not sure what
those was based on but they were I know
in Salem it was
if you had a church property and you
weren't using anything out and I'm just
I don't remember the exact number now
but if you're not using the land outside
of let's say 200 feet and don't quote me
on that then we will tax everything
outside that area and that created a big
problem in s we went to the um the Town
Council um there was a process to kind
of reverse that but that triggered the
idea that why you know you know why why
are we taxing some of these things we
should be better taxed I so I the answer
to your question is I don't know how
they discovered that um but you'd have
the same and and so that could be the
concern my my guess is your your
followup would be then how are they
going to know if the money is being used
for paying the minister and so forth but
follow it's it's the same it's the same
issue of not knowing you know are they
yeah there there's those sort of things
that make it difficult to
determine okay I as a followup I was
just going to describe the fact that I
am putting a bill in to uh do payment
low of taxes for nonprofits but um P or
the um churches are exempt from that
bill so but I just wanted to get it out
there that the spill might be coming
down the pike thank you any further
question
questions and I've got a couple of
thoughts on this on First on in Kan not
in Kanan in uh Grafton town uh there was
a man who put up a church uh in a place
that had been a church uh and declared
it a
church and I can't remember on
representative spar seems to remember
this I can't remember what the outcome
of that was but I know that it was
contested for quite a while
um and uh but second I really think we
ought to set our researcher Gen 4 onto
looking as how this has been handled in
the past and that it really is also a
local issue it should have had an L on
it uh and ought we ought to to consult
the municipal and County
committee about it and now I have
spurred
representative thank you uh excuse me
for not having been here earlier it was
a family issue medical um the question
that I have is regarding as an
organization shall not claim more than
one exemption under this sub paragraph I
understand what you're trying to say a
particular Parish however the parishes
both the Episcopalian Church and the
Lutheran Church and the Catholic church
and are all part of one larger
organization which has multiple churches
apply we may need to look at that um you
know because we we want to make sure
that a
large church that that isn't made up of
little Parts doesn't take advantage of
this you know we're trying to we're
trying to I think you understand the
intent of it so if there's some question
uh with that that's something we could
on yeah the I was also remember the um
Eastern Orthodox dasis has or patriarchy
has uh several churches in in the state
as well so it it it covers a large a
large number of main mainstream churches
as well as the individual smaller
churches uh so I I do think that
maybe some tweaking is needed sir thank
thoughts one question one more question
thank you um was there any uh besides
the assessor did you approach any of the
local folks the select board or anything
about
this um we for the thing that happened
last year we did we brought it to the
Town Council and they directed The
assessor to
reconsider um and um because this $4,000
that I just mentioned here that we pay
every year it had been you know uh
almost doubled and so we did get that
reversed this but all what I'm saying is
it prompted me though to look back and
say why you know look at this part of
the law and
say yes we we can't afford to have a
pastor live in this parsonage but now
that we we're renting it out we're being
taxed on it but we're actually still
using the money to pay the pastor and
maintenance thank you if there are no
other
questions on
then I thank the representative for
speaking and call on thank you former
gay I'm Betty gay from Salem former
representative and a church member All
My Life um and now actually a member of
two
churches it's federal law that a church
usually has to use to prove that they
are a
501c3 so the town doesn't usually have
to figure that one out
um this whole issue came up a couple of
years ago when we had a substitute
assessor who actually had been the
assessor for Salem several years before
went off to greener pastures and then
came back as a quote temporary well two
years after he was there
temporarily he joined with uh apparently
he adopted the opinion by other
assessors that you could make points if
you could bring in more tax money so
they were Stu this was a movement across
the state and if you know about it when
it happened in your town we could get an
idea how when did that happen but it's
really recent uh you know two years
three at the most um and he was a a
member of a church and uh he was very
unembarrassed to think that it was okay
to tax
churches uh because he very strictly
interpreted the line here that's on line
five directly for religious training or
for other religious purposes by any
regularly recognized and constituted
denomination so he went with a really
strict interpretation that it's not
religious to enjoy grounds around your
building in in when he was dealing with
St David's and Triumph and cross it was
like at the edge of the building that
was taxable and he went to every single
Church in town walked it with the
minister Triumph and cross was able to
um what do you call where you bury you
you bury the the uh ears or you spring
scatter the ashes that was considered a
cemetery that's not taxable so St D
Triumph cross went well we missed that
St David's rents out it's very small
Church uh has Wetland has trees has
grass and a small congregation and he
decided that you could tax wetlands and
trees and a little bit of most of the
grass but you could save a little bit of
the grass for people doing something
outside it was just to the point of
ridiculous saying that you know Outdoors
had nothing to do with the the Ambiance
if that's appropriate word of being
there
um uh uh Grace
Grace Church has lots of trees lots of
wetlands right next door to triumphant
cross that had the the U cem the
cemetery they got taxed on all of it and
I friends couldn't believe that they
were taxing Wetland of all things you
know so it was just to the point of
ridiculous that churches were being
taxed
anyway and uh in the case
of uh the church that I grew up in St
Michaels in Lamar Texas the dasis
decided pisc church the dasis decided
that it was not a good idea to keep
providing uh homes for the ministers
because when they retired they didn't
have any property so they changed over
and said you need to buy to to buy
property and I Remember Mama telling me
that the priest told her his hands shook
because in those days that was a long
time ago $1,000 was a lot to pay and he
said his hand shook as he wrote his ,000
check every month but that meant that a
whole lot of churches ended up owning
property that they still needed to pay
the
minister but now so they had the extra
expense and now you know you need the
income from the property that you
already invested in so to me this is
just a really sensible way to address
the issue that many many churches have
you've invested in the property you own
it but you need to pay your minister his
housing allowance in cash so why not
take it from the property that you
already own to me it's not fair at all
that right now the churches are having
thank you are there any questions would
you take questions oh of course I any
questions because it's fun to
talk I miss being a
rep okay yeah I've seen you on the
internet quite a lot and not as much
lately so um there don't seem to be any
questions thank you very much just vote
well and we now have um someone in
opposition uh Brad Dees deis I can't
remember D sorry from uh the municipal
Association thank you uh Madam
chairwoman and thank you to the
committee for letting me speak today my
name is Bry Dees I represent the ner
Municipal Association and I am speaking
in opposition to um this is House Bill
585 um for just as our general position
um we are against the expansion of tax
exemptions or credits that are mandated
onto the municipalities and this would
um do that and especially when it's
property that could have commercial uses
or uses not in line with uh religious um
with the religious Doctrine or
charitable P purposes claimed under RSA
7223 that would be uh reported to the
assessor or the contract assessor to the
municipality
um I also want to mention there was some
discussion about assessors becoming you
know a Statewide movement as to being
more strict in their application of RSA
72 colon 23 for charitable and religious
tax exemptions um this was born out of a
decision made by the uh the New
Hampshire Board of tax and land appeals
the btla um which exists with the
Authority Under RSA 71-b colon 5 they're
over on South Fruit Street so about mile
that way um so their decision is the
reason why some assessors were a lot
stricter with how they interpreted this
some were a little bit looser some were
so loose that it was not in line with
the law and the btla said you need to be
assessing these properties by Statute um
I will also mention there's a near
identical bill um not entirely the exact
verbiage but essentially the same
substance and that would achieve nearly
the same thing that was heard yesterday
in front of Municipal and County
government um it's house bill
425 and um so that kind of creates some
complexities where we have two bills
trying to achieve very similar things
slightly different ways and slightly
different operation and I'm unsure how
the two committees will be able to
reconcile that um so that alone you guys
could report out and theoretically
report out on what you know two bills
that are doing very similar things um
additionally um this bill would require
additional reporting requirements for
the property owners and assessors um the
assessors currently they can confirm if
a pastor is residing in the residence
because they'll go by to these churches
or Charities um religious organizations
and they will confirm meeting with
someone from the board of directors hey
are you using this building for
religious purpose are you having at
least two religious events religious
ceremonies a year and um is there
someone who is your pastor living in
that parsonage so the s do that they
have to fulfill that to make sure that
it's all reported correctly to the
Department of Revenue Administration
they require that
um my third point is um the term funding
for and then specifically the term quote
standard religious programs is not used
anywhere at least in RSA um 72 colon 23
and it's not defined which is kind of
where this issue is coming from why the
btla has had to make additional rulings
on this is because of the know
additional language the legislature
keeps adding that's vague and tough for
them to interpret um what is a standard
religious program to one assessor it
might mean one thing to another it might
mean another thing and to the btla who
will ultimately have to make some kind
of Quasi judicial decision they would
end up determining that rather than the
legislature so it's usually best when
laws are written well defined so then we
don't have to go through a a patchwork
process the assessors themselves they
don't like that um I'll also mention
that um to the point of renting out
these properties um charitable
organizations and nonprofits they don't
use they start turning a property for
like a commercial use or renting it out
um you know that's outside of their
religious Doctrine or their charitable
purpose um they you know that that will
make it so they're no longer tax exempt
what a lot of organizations do is they
have a suggested donation but they can't
provide services or fees um you know as
part of their duties unless it's
mentioned you know some kind of specific
charitable purpose that they have um
that's tied to why they were established
and with a religious organization their
tact exemption is usually tied to a
specific religious Doctrine or an
organization that has a religious
Doctrine so if you're a Baptist Church
you might be part of the league of
southern baptist churches or um so you
can point to that religious Doctrine
that's what you're operating under um
I'll also mention um the term on Section
line um more than one worship building
so one worship building um that could
mean an organization could rent their
building six days a week for
non-religious uses which is outside of
their religious Doctrine or their
charitable purpose that's established
under 72 colon 23 so um I mean for some
a lot of those operational issues and
the fact that there are 10 bills trying
to change you know whether or not
charitable or um religious organizations
how their tax I mean the current
standard is if the land and the building
qualifies as the charitable purpose of
the organization or the religious
purpose for the religious organization
that's claim claiming the tax exemption
then they get it all other property that
they own that isn't being utilized
actively um by the organization that's
subject to tax because it's not falling
under the qualifications for 72 col 23
so sorry to throw out a lot of technical
things to you I know that's a lot but um
I think it's important you have that
context because we've shared it with
Municipal and County government um
bills thank you very much um are there
any questions to start representive ol
uh thank you for taking my question I
was just reviewing the IRS regulations
on uh churches which they consider a
church automatically if they declare to
be a part of yeah blah blah
501c3 their l
for extraneous
property is that it's got to be a
business or a trade it's got to be
continually used for that
purpose and that the uh income derived
from that purpose does not substantially
support the church are you saying that
New Hampshire's taxation laws differ so
radically that the a a property can be
ex exempt from Federal Regulation paying
taxes as a
501c3 but then have to pay a local
property
tax I am not aware of the IRS code and I
haven't reviewed it um I following the
state statute and how the state statute
how the btla has told assessors to
assess charitable or religious property
is and what the court standards have
been M numerous cases probably at least
10 over the last 30 years is property
that's exempt is only that that's being
used for the charitable or the religious
purpose so the building and any other
kind of property that might be
contiguous to that building that's
utilized so like a parking lot all other
property that's outside of that does
fall under the assessment and what's
happened is some assessors have decided
to say the entire lot the entire
property is um not subject to assessment
and the btla has said that that is an
incorrect interpretation of 72 colon 23
that it's only at least a according to
the statute it's only that property
actively being used for the charitable
purpose or the religious
purpose thank youing my question thank
you thank you is there um oh yes
represent SP thank you madam chair is
there an ex so if you as a church you're
investing in uh any sort of investment
stocks bonds mutual funds uh that is
exempt from federal tax taxable income
Cor correct I I can't speak to the
federal statutes of how their investable
income would be taxed I think it is um
and I guess that was my questions I
guess the property tax is is localized
so you're saying that is something that
the local jurisdiction can choose to tax
or not that
entity the local jurisdiction doesn't
get a choice the legislature has in this
bill would not have a choice right no no
no in in current statute the legislature
determines how property is assessed and
the legislature says only
the reading of the statute as
interpreted by the btla what they've
told the assessors is that it's only
property so on the lot it's only that
real property that's actively being used
for a charitable or religious purpose
any other property that is even on the
same lot or contiguous Lots that's
subject to property taxation it's part
of the assessment for the town okay
thank
you on represent I didn't realize your
light was on representative BS
and
then thank you madam chair thanks for
taking my question
so it sounds to me like the btla needs
to get get out of this Arena unless
they're going to go do their homework it
sounds to me like this is a Witch Hunt
against the the churches M synagogues do
you agree I um I wouldn't agree with
that characterization they're trying to
interpret what is a complicated statute
that even assessors have had varying
interpretations
follow representative ORS I think that
question is out of
order don't you think that the btla
needs to learn what the federal laws
before they enact laws that are outside
Federal representative ORS yes ma'am uh
he has said and it is true that our law
in local issues on
supersedes the the fed well is different
from the federal law and has
respectfully disagree but that's okay
thank you very much okay I I would like
to clarify Madam chairwoman that um I'm
not disagreeing with whether or not the
federal how the federal statutes
interplay here I'm saying this is a lot
more complicated in the board of tax and
land appeals their job is to when when
appeals come before them from Property
Owners about whether or not they should
be assessed or not um because sometimes
there are disputes between the governing
bodies that oversee the assessment which
would be a board of Select of a order of
assessors it goes to the btla and it's
up to them they take on a quasi judicial
role similar to a superior court where
they basically make a ruling over how
the statutes to be interpreted and it's
a legislature who determines what
statutes exist for them to interpret and
if there's vagueness in the statute to
make sure there's uniformity they make
an interpretation a ruling and inform
the assessors and the
municipalities thank you that's a very
good explanation of what has been
occurring for a very long long time in
this state on representative Bolton
thank you mad chair um regarding um
other nonprofits like Hospital grounds
or the university um they have uh
basically acres and Acres of U like
Woods might that fall in or they have
they're under a separate statute I won't
speak to the State University system
because they might fall under a separate
statute um just because of the
uniqueness of how the legislator
established the system and sometimes the
legislature you know there are some
sections of um chapter 72 where they're
like for example there's a specific
section that I haven't reviewed recently
about granges so sometimes there are
some unique classifications but when it
comes to like a hospital that was
established for a charitable purpose
which there are many hospitals that are
nonprofits that are established for
charitable purpose um the land that
they're utilizing in the building that
they have for that charitable purpose
that is tax exempt but the other land so
if you have a hospital and they use two
acres of their land for their physical
plant their Hospital their parking Etc
that is tax sorry that is not taxed
because it's charitable purpose but if
they had 98 other Acres of 100 acre lot
that would be taxed they could put it in
current use if they wanted to Etc but
that does have to be it comes under the
assessment very good thank
and thank you very much thank you uh
could you is there any way you could put
this in writing since this is the first
time our committee has had to deal with
this I I do have some written testimony
on a separate bill that'll be coming to
you guys I would really prefer that the
Department of Revenue Administration
provide this committee with its legal
expertise and guidance I mean the
municipal Association we're here to
represent the municipality's interest um
the Department of Revenue administration
at least you know my my opinion is they
they should be providing you with the
legal guidance of the interplay with the
btla the federal statutes that the uh
Vice chairman mentioned I mean this is
you know there's a lot of moving parts
and they have experts who should
understand the interplay between these
moving parts and provide written
guidance so I can if there is no
additional and the committee feels as if
it needs it to move forward so but I
would really prefer to defer to them
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify for or
against this
bill then I'm going to close the
chapter
you
mil
okay the time being 12 11 get started on
uh HB 688 so I'll open the public
hearing on HP 688 and recognize
representative
om thank you Mr chairman for the record
representative Bill M of nashille
Hillsboro
10 I'd like to talk about the situation
we have in ASA relative to the uh new
property that's coming in for expanded
gambling namely at the Sears
casino and the situation we currently
have is that our former Sears store
which is a fairly large uh Box Store 18
180,000 square fet is now be being built
out into a
casino if you pull out the accessor
cards you find that the current of the
property is $116 million and that's
varied between about 10 million and 16
million over the past 10
years vacant use for retail but
currently about 16
million the new tax rate in NASA is
$15.90 per thousand so the property tax
that would be realized to the city of
NASA for the property at the current
assessment is about $300,000
now would there be any reason to have
that assessment Changed by the tax
assessor I think the owner can argue
that well I've got the same square
footage 180,000 Square fet I have the
same up space it's the same business
district it's the same building it's not
new construction I've blown out a new
entrance in the back to the uh side that
faces tank Massachusetts where there
used to be a fire door now it's going to
be a main entrance but I think you can
argue that the assessor from the city of
Nash will um be tough to assess it at a
higher rate given the parameters of the
current situation same building same
size same square
footage so what's the
problem well it teres the use of that
building in my opinion and I back that
up by by handing out a 20-year study
called casinos crime at community cost
which is all in your
handout and this tries to look at what's
happened to counties in the United
States when a casino's been introduced
compared to other counties where they've
not had
casinos so they took a look at these
3165 counties all over the
US and looked at the 178 of those
counties that have class three gaming
devices slot
machines and what do we
find well if you go through the summary
of this report which looks at all the
studies that have been uh collecting
data on crime and Community
costs they conclude that the crime in
Casino counties is very low after the
opening there's people who've got new
jobs
there's some uh additional commercial
activity that goes into these casinos
these counties that have casinos and
that's a u sometimes a net benefit for
the first year or
so
however after years um three and four
there appears to be
a a defined interest of crime going up
attributed to the casinos
and that particularly starts with
increased robbery after the first year
increase aggravated salt after years
three and burglary and larly increases
after years
four so what's the cost to the city that
hosts these
properties the study I have before you
analyzes that
cost and determined that the cost per
adult in these communities is $75 per
adult for the impacts of crime in the
city and that fee that cost of
$75 was in 1996 if you adjust it for
2025 so i' estimate that the cost to n
for a casino of the size is about $150
per adult in
2025 Nashville currently has 1,000
residents roughly 71% are
adults I'm saying 2/3 for simple
calculation so if we have 2third of the
adults um facing an average cost of $150
that's about a $9 million
expense to the city of
Nashua for hosting a
casino and I suggest that if we're going
to have this kind of expense to host
this kind of property that the city
that's hosting it should have some sort
of
mitigation now prior bills that have
come before Ways and Means which had uh
a very comprehensive Casino analysis and
mitigation typically have mitigation to
the host cities of the uh cost of
posting this particular Enterprise and
that typically is about 3% of the gross
slot machine Revenue to the host
communities with another 1% going to the
abdy communities and a final 1% going to
the host County now at the present time
we have no such mitigation to the host
casinos we don't have a casino Bill we
have historic horse racing bill that
evolved out of chable gaming which has
done quite well but now it's been
morphed into a full-blown casino and we
don't have a casino build so my proposal
here is one
Band-Aid until we can get a full Casino
Bill to get some mitigation to the city
and towns that are hosting these
properties and if you add my proposal
up and say that well we have a a new tax
which is a Enterprise tax for the use of
the property as a casino we have the
standard real estate
tax uh which is perhaps
$300,000 maybe more on the
buildout but the local community will be
to add a Enterprise tax which I've
defined as up to twice the assessed
property
value and if we have a Enterprise tax of
twice the assess value that may be
another 60 thou $600,000 for a total tax
to the city of NASA of $1
million and that's really a small
portion of the uh tax that would
be anticipated had we had a casino bill
that would give 3% of the gross revenue
to the host cities and
towns and with that I'll take
questions okay seeing none thank you
elmy uh Susan El me city of
Lebanon
uh and I just wanted to provide some
information which is irrelevant to the
actual subject of this bill but which is
um
due to where
um it was placed in um our
rs72 uh
one is actually the resident tax for
those of you who are not in New
Hampshire uh by I think it was on
somewhere around
1980s no yeah on every single adult in
New Hampshire had to pay
$10 to their local government in order
to be able to
vote whatever year that was uh the sup
US Supreme Court or or the the state
government itself figured out okay this
is
unconstitutional but I think it was
probably the US Supreme Court because we
were uh
um it they left the statute on the
books and they took out some pieces of
it it is still there uh I would
suggest that if we are going to pass
anything like this um which I also
um
on
co-sponsored
on because I've been through how much it
cost to do to allow a major Casino in
your state which we now have too many of
um
the um this section uh 71a be totally
wiped out and replaced with this instead
of adding it on and if not that we put a
bill in next
year to get rid of the resident
tax which has not been collected since
unconstitutional and that's all I wanted
to say about it except that I
agree that all of the bills that we
dealt with before for major casinos and
we dealt with a lot of them on required
a lot more payment to this to the city
or town that was hosting it uh and to um
to the county
usually so thank you thank you do we
have any questions for represent
and now I want to um bring up uh former
State Rep Pat brami welcome back to Ways
and
Means
again thank you Mr chair and
members I wasn't planning on coming
today but then I read this
bill and I went wow that's all I can say
Wow first off uh I did look up the uh
this the statute that it's under is I'll
just follow on to what representative
Aly is saying it's it's uh 72 colon
1 which uh way back when charged $10 a
resident uh anybody from 18 to
65 uh this tax and and I don't think
anybody ever adopted it but it's on the
books correctly it's on the books so
this new tax I will call it the uh
Enterprise tax
so first I thought maybe there's other
Enterprise maybe there are other
businesses being charged as Enterprise
tax there's no such thing as Enterprise
tax this is being created by this bill
okay
so and the wow is when you read the text
of the
bill first off I use the example I guess
representative om used the example of U
what's got to Nash at $15 million I use
I use an example of 20
million let's say the assess value is 20
million and it let's say it's $20 per
thousand so that facility would be
paying 4,000 in property
taxes by the way more than enough to
cover any extra police coverage or
anything like
that um but this bill says that we we
will tax two times the assess value not
at the not at the rate the actual assess
value now please correct me if I have a
wrong but that would mean that that that
facility worth assess that 20 million
would have to pay 40 million a year in
this
tax um please correct me if I'm wrong if
you've read the bill do I have that
wrong I I don't think I do so which is
totally out of re totally
unrealistic so and unfair because here's
the unfair part
is why are we just picking on
casinos uh charal Gaming facilities I
mean here we go we're going to create a
tax just for charal Gaming
facilities that that that doesn't make
sense at all let's say it passed then
you can have people in these towns going
because it's a municipal tax they're
going to say well let's let's tax the
movie theaters or let's tax something
else you know just
because um and I don't I don't think
this would pass the muster of of the
Supreme Court anyway uh because it's
really picking and choosing winners and
losers
here um we have similar bills that are
not uh that come before Ways and Means
over the years the big one has always
been U Portsmith and Hampton folling a
bill to add like a $2 room tax on top of
the uh on top of the U um uh room meals
tax and we've always killed those bills
here
always killed them uh I think in many
respects on a bipartisan basis because
again it's a slopy slope if we start
taxing that we're going to attx
something else and we don't in New
Hampshire we don't we don't do these
things as far as I just want to read we
we addressed the issue
of um I'm going to go to my report the
the the Char gaming report from the
because I actually brought
up that you know right now the these
facilities are only charged a fee of
$750 a year to renew their their license
okay even for me it seemed a little low
but here's what the I'm going to read
the text of what the discussion was in
the committee the the question was
should we recommend increasing the
current 750 annual license for Fe
assessed to East facility that is
licensed the discussion was the annual
license fee of 750 has not changed since
2015 there was a recognition through
discussion that this fee was never
designed to cover full cost of
Regulation since most of the cost is
covered by the 10% gross Gaming revenue
received by the state for table games
and the 16.77% received from
HHR there was some discussion about a
tiered fee structure based on size of
facility and I brought that up uh again
there was recognition that the larger
the facility that the more revenues that
there will be more revenues generated
for the state a portion of which is
utilized for
regulation with this discussion here's
the recommendation it was decided not to
recommend increasing annual uh facility
fee at this time then there was another
um and here's the question shall the com
the commission shall examine whether
host communities should share in the
proceeds of any charal gaming
establishment so this goes more to what
this is being proposed so that and
here's the discussion the legisl
legislature this past session voted to
allow hosting municipalities to receive
up to 10 dates of sponsorship if no
charities could be found to utilize
these dates at this juncture it appeared
and this was when I say this year it was
year or two ago okay now at this
juncture it appears that no
municipalities have received dates
because those dates are precious and the
Charities are are taking up the dates
the discussion then con uh then U
concerned whether these facilities
should be paying municipalities for
police coverage more than a restaurant
or a bar
these facilities already pay property
taxes like every other business it was
also pointed out that all these
facilities already have paid security to
protect the public and what they do and
not to mention cameras everywhere
there's cameras everywhere in these
facilities so here's the recommendation
of the commission the consensus of the
commission is that other than the
current statute that would allow
municipalities to utilize uh the use
charity days no action on this issue
needs to be taken at this time
so the the commission we've looked at
this we've addressed this uh
and again my conclusion is that this res
resident uh this uh Enterprise tax is
new it's it's it's picking on one
industry which doesn't is not not really
fair and uh and not only that it's
exorbitant in terms of the way the bill
is written in terms of what that tax
would be and that's the end of my
conclusion thank you do I have questions
yes representative
shamberg thank you Mr chairman uh thank
you representative honorable
representative going to lines 2 three
four of this bill uh maybe I'm missing
something here when you mentioned if if
the property was assessed at 20 million
it would be a $40 million tax are you
saying are you talking the entire
property because I as I keep reading I
have a comma to be known as Enterprise
ta shall be assessed on every historic
racing and charitable gaming facility so
you're talking the entire
facility yes and not my bill I
understand I'm just trying to make sure
I understand that it's
including the the machines on the inside
right yes that's the way I interpret it
the physical facility itself that's the
way I interpret it
and a tax amounting to two times all
right I just wanted to make sure I was
reading this yeah I'll read it out
loud the tax amounting to two times the
assessed property value of the of an
Enterprise to be known as the Enterprise
tax shall be assessed on every historic
racing and Charo gaming facility as
governed by RSA
284 with 100 or more machines okay
there's a little subtlety here and 100
or more so we're saying that you have to
have at least first off it says machines
I went to
284 there's no there's no definition of
machine that says it's a historic racing
machine so if this B bill would to be
brought forward you should adjust that
to say ter gaming machines because
that's what they mean
uh but it's saying it so this is really
targeting the larger facilities the way
I read it it's it's the the ones that
have well I mean I think the the new
nashaa U the Nash is going to have like
12,00 uh historic racing machine
something like that so 100 is modest
number but but again some of the
facilities like I said yesterday do not
have historic racing so this wouldn't
apply to them
either so anyway do I answer this
question Tom okay thank you
representative
duet thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
I some of the testimony we heard was uh
relative to past legislative efforts to
have full-blown
charity uh sorry full-blown Casino
gaming in New Hampshire do you happen to
remember how many pieces of legislation
and coupled with that was a component
for the
localities um yeah I believe it was
three% um how many times that came in
front of the legislature so I was legisl
for 12 years and um in the early years
we we have a bill every other year um
probably and my friend and I say my
friend uh senator delandro who just
retired um he would bring those bills to
us every every year and the last time he
came uh this is a story I'll tell he
came he presented it he pounded the
table I'll come back every year unless
you guys passed my this is real casinos
not terrible gaming you st if those were
here remember this and I'm going to come
back
again and then he came he came and
um um the bill didn't pass out of
committee I ran into
Lou in the hallway a day later he says
Pat how my bill do I said look you
testified and then 10 people testified
against and nobody testified four so you
were you were the General charging the
hill but you had no troops behind you so
and after that he he never filed the
bill again so I would say three or four
times that's a long way of saying that
there's been three or four bills over
the years we in the house rejected them
over and over again follow up follow up
so it failed
a few times and now we have the model
that we have right now so let me just
ask
you this this is by definition a new tax
and it's basically opening the
floodgates for a locality to tax any and
all Enterprise yes it's setting a
precedent it's setting a precedent thank
you representative Yul thank you Mr
chair
good to see you again I didn't have a
sense to say hello to you yesterday
Jordan I
know um as a former Vice chair you're
aware of the house role regarding
constitutionality and the vice chair's
role on that right therefore would you
please send me your comments since you
raised the question uh regarding that so
that we can do what we got to do I get
to do what I got to do that's first
question for you if you could do that
if this tax were to be
applied to to corporations as
written is it your opinion that most of
the charitable gaming large charitable
gaming organizations would just
disappear from New
Hampshire I don't know if they would
disappear uh they they have some options
and especially with the
machines um they they can control
there's a range in which the payout are
allowed um and they can make them pay
out less so that they can retain more
Revenue that's one potential if they
wanted to wanted to keep their their net
revenue level that's reasonable the
other thing that that bothers me a bit
is that we have all these yes there's a
lot of outside companies now coming in
they're investing millions and millions
in renovating these facilities these
malls that are dying there's two the the
other one is
Rockingham uh there's another group
that's coming and wants to put a casino
in the old Rockingham um that's one of
the other big uh
Stores um so in a way they're kind of
helping save these malls they're helping
by by putting these facilities in there
so um I'll just leave it at that I mean
I it follow up Sir follow up so your
comment your suggestion would be given
the testimony we just heard yesterday
regarding on how many charitable
organizations rely upon both charitable
uh gaming table gaming it itself as well
as historic horse racing this would have
a dilit terious effect on the services
that they needed services that they
provide to Citizens is that correct uh
yes because what what I was trying to
say is that there's some wiggle on in
terms of the percentage payout out of of
the historic racing machines like any in
any jurisdiction the statute is very
clear on what what the range is and they
and and they they try to keep it that
the payouts are higher so that people
want to play you put them too low people
don't want to play because they're not
winning so it's a magic number somewhere
uh that that they shoot for I mean in
Vegas not that I'm an expert on Vegas
but in Vegas there's a lot of
competition right and they're all
competing for and and people who play
these machines a lot look for the the
the facility that pays off the
best so I'm this this is a uh a
supposition on my part that this is one
thing that they could possibly do to
make up the loss Revenue if I had if we
had to pay if I had to pay $40 million a
year that's going to eat into my
profits and your question is will that
impact the Charities I think indirectly
it could because they'll they'll change
the formula so that they get better
payouts uh that U as well
questions yes represent elberger thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
questions yeah thank you and again I'm
still trying to formulate because
there's a lot of stuff going on here
um I asked at an another hearing uh I
believe I asked the the gaming commit
about are there any casinos in the state
that are hurting and the response was no
right
um you mentioned your concern about this
potential Enterprise tax being uh role
of the
municipalities being a potentially being
able to pick and
choose what kind of businesses they
might want to do that and that
municipalities could potentially get
dates only there aren't any because the
casino owners apparently there's there
doesn't seem to be any other
decision-making Authority the casino
owners pick and choose whom they're
giving their dates to so municipalities
are effectively blocked out by the
decision of the
casinos they're blocked can I this s i
part yeah they're blocked out because
there are so many Charities on mine
wanting to that bill was illc conceived
that created that I mean it was like I
don't know I don't know I wasn't here on
that past but it it said well we'll give
we'll give the uh municipalities 10
days they really weren 10 days available
I mean every single day is is absorbed
by a
charity so I just read that just so you
know that there was an attempt to be
made and and that one didn't work um
okay I'm I'm wondering though
if your
objection to this potential tax is that
it's a
municipality getting to pick and choose
how it is that it seems to be okay for
the casinos to pick and choose to whom
they're going to give their
days so that the municipalities don't
have a shot at it the picking and
choosing part is still up for grabs in
terms of this next commission if you
read the we were made a recommendation
we listed a whole bunch of issues that
need to further be addressed and one of
them was who gets to pick the Charities
it's always been in statute that the
that the facilities get to pick the CH
they Charities they have to go first go
to the aot to be approved that they're a
real charity and all that um and they
have to be a charity for a year or two I
forget what it is maybe a year we just
want people saying I'm a charity now and
and saying I want two years is two years
thank you
so um so I I think I answer your
question but it's it's more or
less thank you representative
Yuri thank you representative Elbert
stimulated a question my I remember the
discussions that we had uh regarding the
uh operation of the various Charities
and one correct me if I'm wrong I'm a
little hazy on that because didn't
attend the commission meeting like uh
like you
did but
aren't the organizations that run these
casinos and these gaming rooms aren't
they required by law to be
profitable that I can't I can't remember
that in order to make I I think
they it's free
enterprise if they're not profitable
they're going to go out of business so
uh we we certainly have a a free
enterprise model here
uh that's what's led to we having 14
licenses um now that the legislature two
years ago or last year I guess put put a
cap on we have 14 licenses and they they
they've approved another five for
another so you can go up to 19
facilities that's that's just for the
historic racing license part of it it's
not a license but approval for historic
racing so
um so right now we have a capit number
facilities at 19 uh for at least 5 years
um but but yes all of them seem to be
profitable we have somebody from Lottery
here could could address that if you
really want that question
answered thank you more current with
more current information any other
questions okay seeing none thank you
thank you for thank you for
Preston thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee uh my name is
Alicia Preston I represent the New
Hampshire charitable gaming operators
Association uh I'll be brief because
representative bramy really hit on a lot
of our points uh we are here to oppose
this bill we know of no other industry
in the state of New Hampshire where
municipality is allowed to tax one
industry in particular we also think the
discussion of this increased cost of
shable gaming being housed in the
community is no different than any
increased cost of a sporting event a
concert venue a bar a restaurant I live
at Hampton Beach we have two of these
charitable casinos and we have numerous
music venues and bars and I assure you
the Minal Municipal Services required
are far less at the two casinos and many
of the other businesses at Hampton Beach
just like all properties in New
Hampshire terrible Gaming facilities pay
property taxes every one of the
operating facilities have spent a lot of
money improve improving them over the
last several years which has increased
their value and then increased the money
obviously they're paying to the
municipality and let's not forget in
situations like this there are no
children in the school system from the
property taxes they're paying so for
those reasons we are opposing this
legislation thank you representative
duet thank you Mr chair and thanks for
taking my question so just making me
obvious obvious so I would assume that
they're paying business Enterprise tax
business profit tax they're paying that
and of course they're paying the tax
that comes out to the Charities and the
state revenue in the money they make and
the profit they
have representative opal thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question um both you and representative
bramy had brought up a point I thought
was interesting and I just want to make
sure I
understand you're telling this committee
you believe it's wrong for a tax scheme
to tax one industry or one kind of
company
differently than others is that correct
I believe the state of New Hampshire
should not be allowing municipalities to
tackle one industry over another yes
what about the
state for well I mean the state does in
different Industries the charitable
gaming is taxed differently than a
restaurant right there's rooms and meals
tax and but that's from a state
construct as opposed to municipality
like I said I know of no other industry
that allows munici the state allows a
municipality to tax on their own thank
you
[Music]
anybody
you um I we have Dr here and we have
Lottery here um I have a pink card I'm
assuming uh Lauren you only if people
have questions or is there something you
good morning members of the um Ways and
Means Committee my name is Lauren O
Sullivan and I am the senior Financial
Analyst at the Department of Revenue um
as with all bills we do not have a
position on this bill but we are coming
here today with um some of our
interpretation and we want to make sure
we understand um what the bill is trying
to
do and I I was listening to some of the
testimony we heard so far and I think it
answered some of our questions but one
thing that we were concerned with was
that the term assess property value was
not defined in this bill and our re we
weren't sure whether this refers to to
the Enterprise property value as
reported by the city or town on the
pa28 the inventory of taxable propert
property pursuant to RSA chapter 74 or
um tax liability for property that would
otherwise exist so we and it sounds like
what I heard that was based on what the
property taxes um assessed for that for
that charitable gaming commission um
facility so we would just need
maybe have that clarified because there
were three different interpretations on
what that would have
meant also um within our reading we saw
um this was supposed to be an optional
text but it but to me at least it read
that you have to um elect to opt out of
the Enterprise tax so if the intent was
to opt in or opt out um maybe uh amend
some of that language to make that
clearer and also so
um also one thing that is missing from
the bill so in order for the Dr to
assess the 100 machines at the casinos
we don't necessarily have the the rulle
making authority to allow the
that and open to any other questions
okay any questions represent viy um
thank you for taking my question are
questions
um it was it was questioned earlier
whether or not bet BPT meals and rooms
Etc are paid by the
casinos is that a
correct that's correct they do pay yep
follow up follow up do you have a list
of roughly how much money in total I
don't want break it down by loal but in
total that generates in taxes to the
state revenue to the state I I don't
have that available right now I'm not
entirely sure if I have enough to break
that out but um we can get back to you
with that answer if we can provide it
thank you thank you Mr chair any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you um I see we have Lottery here does
anyone have
questions they weren't necessarily going
to speak but does anyone have questions
okay seeing none then I'll ask if
there's anyone else who would like to
testify on HB 688 before I close the
public
hearing okay saying none I'll close the
public hearing on HP
688 and that well that concludes this
morning's hearings um so our next
hearing is at 1 o'clock we'll hear HP
trick
e
VI
it
the time being excuse me the time being
737 and we'll welcome uh representative
Springer hi thank you Mr chairman it's
great to be back with this a great body
and great committee once again um my
name is Jerry Stringham I'm the state
representative from Lincoln Woodstock
Easton and Livermore and I'm pleased to
introduce House Bill
737 creating local options for games of
chance I'm standing in for the Bill's
Prime sponsor representative Boyd who's
under the weather but on the men uh
today um and uh happy to uh bring the
bill forward um House Bill 737 is not a
gambling bill but a local option zoning
Bill uh I'm not a a gambler myself but
this matter requires local control uh
particularly now since these um uh uh uh
games game centers uh have have historic
horse racing machines in them
potentially uh something much more
analogous uh to slot machines uh this
bill brings similar local rights
relating to casinos that are already in
place for Kino uh the local option
through the local warrant uh article
process uh this bill was initiated uh
last term when a casino wanted to come
uh
into uh the North country and a group of
constituents uh uh came to us uh to
bring forward local option when their
attempt to deal with a casino through
zoning was declared invalid due to the
Dylan rule uh in C uh in committee the
casino Lobby agreed to a local option
concept and helped develop language that
was acceptable to both the casinos and
the local option proponents uh the
casino interests have been very
reasonable and helpful in developing of
this bill uh the constituents have been
uh diligent with this joint work uh it
should be noted that um the bill that
that we're talking about from last term
passed the house with 85% support and a
very a similar bill pass the Senate uh
but um was tripped up in the committee
of conference process so we're back here
um this term uh with virtually an
identical Bill uh the local option
design of this bill conserves the
investment made by the casino operators
already involved and bring only brings
an exit vote if the casino has been uh
abandoned your copy says two years uh
there's uh um uh a longer period such of
for 5 to 10 is also under
consideration um the local option would
give local municipalities a voice in
their process of whether having a casino
in their town or city uh uh it would be
appropriate uh why should local option
be enacted for the casinos uh simply uh
we already do it for for Kino something
um you know much much simpler less less
potential harm less all-encompassing
than something like a casino uh Casino
can be a large presence in the community
economically and has impact on the
business sector uh and certainly
something that the local people will
want to have an option on uh the U you
know you know certainly the risks of
addiction and other uh implications for
the local town uh warrant their input uh
these large influences and risks are the
reasons for local consent for permitting
casinos into the
municipality um there's other others
here that are uh willing as you said as
you said there's been a lot of work done
done on the previous uh bi Anum on this
and uh that received overwhelming house
support and I uh think you'll be
comfortable doing the same uh with with
a couple of minor tweaks uh that you may
feel appropriate so I'll just leave it
at that and uh let others here here who
who have done more work on this than I
have uh speak as well uh but if you have
any questions I'm happy to answer them
now and thank you very much thank you do
you next I'll invite uh former State Rep
bromy thank you Mr chair I know you're
probably tired of seeing me but this is
going to be a change I'm actually here
to uh support this
bill um so and representative stringam
is very modest he he was a member of way
means years ago when I was here as well
so
um the commission addressed this I'm
going to start with this and I like I've
been doing on all these I'm going to
24 the question was should we add the
statute uh a local option given the
citizens of the IP alties the ability to
weigh in on whether charal gaming be
allowed in their communities with all
existing facilities or those five
applications under consideration being
grandfathered in an exempt from the
statue and the discussion went like this
all municipalities in which Lottery
products are
sold Kino and brick and mortar uh sites
for sports betting so all lottery sites
Kino and brick and mortar sports betting
facilities are all opt in opt in this is
an opt out building bill so I'm going to
get back to this in a minute but they're
opt in New Hampshire statutes are silent
on this for charal gaming locations the
legislature tried and as representative
stringam mentioned the legislature tried
at this session meeting last year to
establish an opt out provision which
passed both the house and the Senate was
said and failed in conference committee
on a technicality
um and this is what the recommendation
is the commission recommends that the
legislature pass a local option bill
that would impact any future proposed
charal gaming facility that will exempt
all existing facilities that exist or
that are planned and as I I've been
mentioning there are technically 14
licenses out there right now plus five
that are in the pipeline so that's what
I'm talking about those 19 that that um
and one of them is is well I'll say it
that way
so I I I support this u i my only Twist
on this is that I would prefer it to be
an opt in because of what I just said
all of all of Lottery is opt in and this
is kind of a lottery thing so uh I would
still I would still U support it if it
was opt out but it's an op in you know I
think it would be the preferred way to
do it and um in terms of the bill the
only other concern I had was that we
were protecting those existing
facilities and on the first page of the
bill on lines uh 27 to 30 it reads any
vote by municipality to prohibit games
of chance within its boundaries shall
not apply not apply to the games of
chance operator licensed by The Lottery
Commission or by applicant who has
applied for the games of chance operat
operator license prior to the
of of the of the petition so that would
be the 14 plus the five um I'm not quite
sure what it is now but that's what it
was last year so I support it I I prefer
an op in but um it's up to you folks if
you want to do an opt-in or an opt out
but again just remember the the rest of
Lottery is opt in and I'll give you one
example uh Kino and by the way in The
Kino bill that I supported way back when
I insisted that there be an OP in
provision in the in the statute back
then and uh and uh when you talk to
Charlie McIntyre executive director of
Lottery he gets a call from Portsmouth
every once in a while and say come on in
talk to this to the uh Town U it's a
city city council members and he say I
go I've gone there three or four times
they always vote it down so um so so I
it's reasonable I've never supported
this before because there was never this
option for a facility here in the state
even even before we did historic
racing um and I I and and I used to say
during historic racing we're adding a
new game we're not adding a new facility
we're adding a new game uh and that so
if you want to have a a provision it
should be on the facility not on the
game that's being played
so so that's those are my comments thank
you representative UL
question when such a restriction is put
on on businesses I'm thinking New York
and taxi cab medallions which is similar
where they limit who can participate in
that the value becomes artificially High
to the point that you eliminate
competition to only those who are most
wealthy in order to participate would
not this type of legislation do exactly
the same thing and I have a follow up I
mean we we have plenty of examples of
optin and opt out in our statutes right
now tattoo
parlers porn shops I mean to say uh
other other things that they're opt in
or opt out communities have a say and
what kind of establishments they want so
there's a lot of precedent for that so I
I think the president's already the
president's already said that U you can
restrict if the town decides to restrict
if you want to think in a Libertarian
way um yeah it it restricts certain
businesses but again it's up to the town
that and the the cor to that is when you
restrict one of these charitable gaming
in as we learned yesterday you were
present for most of well probably all
the testimony almost all of it
um it restricts the abil IL of those
Charities to provide needed services to
their client Els because they're limited
as to where they can
operate uh perhaps not getting the same
uh return for their
investment at the different facilities
because of the location I mean it's
easier to go to Sears and the peasant
Lane Mall than it is to go to uh right a
mall in Milford off of 101
so we had a representative from the
Attorney General's office who sat at the
commission with us when we were
discussing this he said that there are
certain certain kinds of things that are
a privileged to do versus not a
privilege to do I don't know if I'm
using the right term but and he says
casinos are one of those things is what
that was his guidance to us okay his
guidance was that this was
restrict understood and yes it is a
privilege um as opposed to it right
however the question was regarding the
generation of Revenue if for example uh
just the the Nash or whatever the house
is going to be called
um is blocked by zoning regulation
I suppose they could do it in the
parking lot do it in Massachusetts but
uh is blocked by zoning regulations
whereas you know 10 miles away at a
lesser
facility and with fewer uh days
available for any particular charity
would not the Charities that are
involved in this lose Revenue because of
this type of selective zoning
uh well
again that's a whole enough issue which
I'm glad you brought it up many towns do
restrict through
zoning Salem does that Salem says it's
on Route 27 the chair can probably
explain it better than I or
representative said long time ago they
zoned without this legislation they Zone
certain po portions of the town that
it's okay to have terrible gaming so
that that that mechanism is already
available to to towns if they want to do
way yes Hudson has an area in the uh has
is part of its zoning Court uh s so
businesses can only uh sexually
oriented businesses can only occur it's
a good acronym SOB for that particular
industry uh can only occur in industrial
area that is allowing the business to
operate but restricting as to where it
can operate this is restricting the
ability of an industry to
exist well I'm not going to disagree
with you but again we have plenty person
in for this
um and uh we've heard plenty of
testimony uh from some folks I think are
going to be testifying today about where
their Community was dead against having
I think the representative Stringham
brought it up uh the North Country
example uh where where the town really
didn't want this and it's it's going to
happen um and and it it's the character
of the town they felt that their town a
small pristine Town um didn't want to
have this not like a city Salem's big
other you know Hudson's pretty big uh so
again we're splitting hears I think a
little bit on this I I think you know
it's it's we we have
restrictions for all other lottery
including here here's a funny story if
you want one I mean when the lottery
first all the all the lottery games
first came came about and some of you
know the
story it was it was an opt in so towns
opt in to topped in opted in and then
years went by and a lot of didn't opt in
because there was no convenience store
in town there was no facility to sell
those tickets the scratch tickets or
whatever then all of a sudden loty
discovers like 10 years later these
towns are are asking for licenses to
open no no wa your town hasn't voted yet
you know so even even with the lottery
itself it's it's been restricted for
years and we were the first Lottery
States right so
um again most most towns have adopted
opt in now for for lottery
games but I think I think the casinos
are you know the charitable gaming
locations are are different uh for a lot
of towns and as long as to me as long as
we're not interfering with the ones who
are grandfathered
in I'm okay with I'm okay with this
bill I mean you and I can argue back and
know represent Al me thank you I'm not
going to go into past history here uh
but on there is in here and I don't know
if
um a future person testifying is going
to uh talk to it both the games of
chance that are much less
damaging and um provide less money uh
and the historic horse racing machines
that provide most of the money uh are in
there together it looks like you have to
okay both of them at the same time in my
community anti-gambling
community on
we we had uh a lot of people saying
saying well the poker parlor is fine
it's not going to cause any problems and
it didn't cause any problems until the
machines came in uh but uh putting it
together so that you have to ban both of
them rather than choose seems to me uh
unnecessary okay my understanding is
that it's it's the uh the uh employee
what was the license called the employee
Alicia what is that called employee
operator employer
license that's what's being restricted
the operator employer license now if the
language doesn't say that that that's
really what it
is and and that that creates the
facility in the in the in the in the in
the in the
location so
um that's my understanding of
it and I'm trying to find on the statute
you you were referring to can you give
number could you put your microphone
on they're there're on
section c and section D in the bill on
page one lines 17 to
22 on requires two questions it looks
like one of them is prohibiting games of
chance the second one is
um shall we provide oh no wait a minute
this is this
different but it does seem I mean we I
didn't see language that's why I was
asking where it is with a casino rather
than a poker parlor because the poker
parlor was there and people thought it
wasn't a problem I think the Poca I
think the Poca is the same license
though yeah so these facilities can open
and just play have poker um and a good
example of that is uh is Chasers and and
Salem which has mostly poker they have
other table games but they mostly poker
and they've been there a long long time
um um matter of fact they they took when
Rockingham Park Rockingham Park was a
charal gaming after it it closed as a
horse racing facility became terrible
gaming and um and they they all the and
they I I remember visiting there once
and I seen all the poker players there
mostly from Massachusetts by the way um
but when that closed they all went over
to Chasers in Salem um but so and
actually they're one of the more
profitable believe it or not and they
don't have historic racing machines and
that's one of the more profitable uh
operations but again I didn't see what
you were orally saying I don't think
there's two licens I think I was
misunderstanding it but there is all
games of chance have to be
banned uh though we did we
legalized poker about 10 years ago
before that it was illegal but people
were all meeting in poker games anyway
uh
and and craps is hardly ever done
because it costs too much money to run
it um and um
roulette um was legal back in the day
when um the traveling circus was taking
the machines around right
um but
um the equivalent of of um slot machines
which is what these are uh and everybody
now accepts that um which but it's still
in the law that they're not allowed um
operation and is considered very
different by a lot of people yeah the
one thing I'll agree with is that there
are certain facilities don't like there
will there certain certain table games
that require a lot more staff to cover
mhm yes I think roulette's one of them
so I I remember going we took tours and
I was on this commission yeah we were on
the
same years ago I was on the one too and
I said why AR the ret Ms going they said
because it it cost us too minutes we had
to have two two people covering it and
there weren't enough players so that
it's silent so but those are local
decisions to to be made because you know
this is in Vegas you know these are
smaller well they're getting bigger at
opal um thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative for taking my
question
um I'm I'm genuinely curious um about
the why you prefer optin versus opt out
I mean as I understand
it the the opt out provision basically
says it's legal until the town votes
right to say
no you're saying you would prefer an
opin provision where it would be illegal
other than the ones that are already
existing or presumably as I understand
the the the the bill if if you've
already dropped in an application you
would be permitted to go forward um but
other than that it would be not legal
until a town actually voted to permit it
and I'm just I'm I'm really genuinely
curious about what you see as the
difference well well well first off to
be consistent with all of a lottery but
that's one so opt
out I I I've said this before on
different things including marijuana
bills um I was always opt in as well
because I thought that the town can miss
it
they could they could miss it and not
you know all of a sudden next thing you
know you have a you have a a terrible
gaming location that you don't want in
your town because they missed it now
obviously this has to go through
planning and stuff like that any of
these things I understand but that's the
only real logic that I have on it that
potentially this one you have to you
have to have an affirmative vote if
someone wants to do
it um and I I don't know I just think
it's a stronger stronger position myself
representative om thank you Mr chairman
yeah P I have a question on the last
comment you made about the u a town not
being able to opt out if I get this
correctly once they've got a device in
their G in their in their
vicinity and I'm specifically thinking
about the nas casino here in NASA where
there was never an opt-in vote by the
citizens of NASA to allow historic
racing now we have a large facility
coming our way and that may or may not
be
controversial but if it does become
controversial it seems to me that
there's no ability in this bill to go
into an opt out provision because it's
already grandfathered is that
correct all right the these current
facilities are grandfathered now in the
case of nasua you had three we have
three
facilities two have merged to become
they'll stop operating become the Nash
and then you'll still have and it's a
Gateway is that the one the other one is
Gateway I think or something like that
so you're going to have two still have
two casinos where but Nash is going to
again if you ask the question well if we
have this
position if that
merger perhaps if those two facilities
decide to create a singular
license this may apply I'm not 100% sure
the way the language is which may be
okay okay uh because it's it's they're
not the same old two facilities that
existed that came together
and but I'm not 100% sure if this
language would cover that or not if that
I think that's your question but it's
too late now I mean that they're they're
protected from this language they are
protected because that anyone who had a
license in process obviously they have
their license now but when we first did
the language in the report they they did
okay now they have their license um and
Lottery can correct me about that but um
I'm quite sure they have they're about
to open right pretty soon yes indeed I
guess the reason I'm asking the question
isn't it
true that the city of
nashwa never had the ability to opt in
for historic horse racing machines yeah
and I and I stated my reasoning for that
is that when we did the historic racing
bill which I was a prime sponsor
and we we said because there was some
discussion about that and we said what
we're talking about is the facilities
not the games that are in the
facility to me CH by adding the historic
racing machines we were adding a game to
facilities that
existed so it was how do you
you know so that that was the logic then
obviously the legislature agreed with me
that because we passed the bill so but
that was the logic uh we weren't adding
a different kind of facility we were we
were the facility
existed we're adding just like we have
roulette or we have the cops table we're
adding some some historic racing
machines now so we went to Mechanical
play as well as just regular table play
so that was the logic then we discussed
it I think we discussed it in this this
committee at the time uh that was always
the argument and U and that's what
so represent you said Thank you Mr
chairman if I may just to maybe help
answer that question at the time also
they were Lucky Seven machines in office
operation at the same time many people
considered those slot machines at the
same time and I I concur it was
basically we were adding a different
game so it wasn't a a completely new
operation or anything it was adding a
game a component game to what was
already in place
so Mr chair can I respond to that sure
and then um
so if you guys had a Lucky Seven bill
yet this year uh lucky s kind of fading
out after now that's historic racing uh
Lucky 7 was was it used to be the P tabs
I mean I had I knew none of this until I
was on Wast of Me by the way um and and
it really was what saved Bingo for many
years because they never made we have a
bunch of Bingo parlers around the state
still that are licensed and and um again
that's an older person's game and uh and
it that's fading but they they couldn't
make it alone just on the Bingo playing
they did the pull s people like to play
the and then someone somewhere along the
line decided Well why do we have the
person going around sing the P tickets
why don't we have them in a dispensing
machine and it's so there's these Lucky
Seven machines is
what representative said is talking
about and so some argued I guess yes
some did argue that well we already have
these mechanical machines already called
Lucky 7 and and actually some of the
Lucky 7 machines
some of the facilities had a license for
Bingo as well as charitable gaming
separate okay it was separate license to
do Bingo and they actually had I think
what you're talking about is some of
them had some of them had the uh the uh
the P the lucky s machines there they're
all gone now because most of the
facilities got rid of bingo uh but
somewhere along the line of this
revolution of charitable gaming it's
they were
there represent um yeah if I could if I
could follow up I just want to clarify
that uh Lucky Sevens and such are
considered Class 2 Gaming uh
regulations and they're not random uh
machines like a slap machine class three
devices are slot machines and class
three devices are historic horse racing
machines so I make the point that even
though City may have had class two
gaming in place that the transition from
class 2 Gaming to class three gaming
there's a major change which has caused
the explosion of the popularity of the
of the machines in Nasha and cause the
sale of these locations from small mom
and pop stores to Major large operations
in major parts of the city right and
consequently because that change has
been implemented I would think that the
cities and towns affected by class three
gaming devices should have the ability
to opt out would you agree
no because yeah yes if there a new city
that doesn't have a a a terrible gaming
location but Nashville no I mean you you
can't you can't I mean it's a pad look
say oh we're going to pass you just
invested uh you know $50 million to
renovate this store into a casino and oh
now we're going to pass a law that says
oh the community can can say no after
the fact that the that won't fly I mean
that's that would be a bad legislation
bad luck uh but if it's another if it's
a new new town that wants to with this
legislation say no F I'm fine with
that and by the way I I agree with you
on yes they they're class two versus
class three you're correct on that I
agree with you on that uh it was a step
up follow follow up Yeah final question
thank you for your patience with me uh
you believe that do you believe that
once a location has been given a license
for a casino which is typically a
three-year license that that license
should remain in place in
perpetuity or do you think that should
have the means to be renewed every three
referendum the license gets re renewed
every year or again the the employer
whatever I said license that's the
license that's the license but they have
to be in good
standing if if and got to remember we
have we have inspectors that check out
these casinos they these terrible gaming
locations there's a whole division there
that that does that AG is involved as
well making sure that that so if all of
a sudden we discover there's a lot of
cheating going on or there's all sorts
of of Hanky Panky going on with the
counting of the money and all of
this facility can lose their
license once they lose their license
then I think this will apply so it's a
real incentive for them to to to play by
the roles and
we and the Consultants we use check
these facilities
out uh and uh and they they they looked
at our rules and our the law our
statutes and our rules associated with
charitable gaming and they gave us a
clean bill of health they said no you
have a lot of the you have a lot of the
safeguards in place to prevent any any
problems and you're you're doing the
right auditing needs to be done like any
other Casino I think some of the rules
are as stringent as some of the bigger
casinos that you see around the country
and because we use this National firm to
evaluate this for us with with those
eyes with those that vision of what
should we see and we said we want to be
the hand highest standard possible and
we got a clean bill of health so thank
you thank you um seeing no more
Warner thank
you hello and I'm Dr Debbie Warner uh I
was here just last week on another item
relating to this on the commission Bill
and appreciate that it was favorably um
moved through your committee I am um
very honored to speak to your committee
Mr chair chairman Mr Vice chairman and
all of the members very much appreciated
um as you can see I did pass out my um
testimony and I have some additional uh
things to go go through I live in
Littleton we're very proud of our little
town north of the notch 6,000 people
with 42
restaurants we have industry we have
shopping we have a very healthy Main
Street we have a wholesome tourist
indust his for seasons and we're just
Mighty proud and uh love our little
wholesome town uh we were surprised and
um taken aback when a casino uh held a
meeting at the high school telling us
they were coming in there with nothing
we can do about it it was going to be
happening and um it was quite alarming
to the community of more than a 100
people came uh 27 spoke 95% of the
people had
very negative um reactions to the news
and uh I was among them uh we put
together we read through the statute and
the reports that had come through
minority and majority reports and
everything and we hooked on to an item
that said that it could be handled by
local ordinance so we put together a
local ordinance to Pro the casino and it
passed by 61 60% um in that same year
and at the same time we got to the
planning board and probably many of you
are on planning boards and select boards
as well I know you do a lot of work for
the government and it's appreciated uh
my husband did serve on both as well so
I know it's it's a lot of effort so I
appreciate it um well we got into the
planning Board review and they said wow
this is very nice but it's not effective
the Dylan rle it has no bite at all and
so we immediately that was January 3D
last year we immediately ran to the
legislature and we managed uh to find a
Safe Harbor and um the municipal and
County which was seemed appropriate for
policy such as this um even though it
pertains to casinos it's about local um
issues and um it went through the
committee we got in there and we um
encountered the casino uh Lobby and
we ended up working together and working
it out Rick Newman who you probably very
much know and was very sad that he has
passed he helped us and we came up with
a very good uh optin bill that we were
able to pass through the house um 280
something to 86 which I thought was a
nice buffer when over to the Senate we
got to the Senate and they turned it
upside down and they said okay it needs
to be Ed out not opt in uh because of
the principle that they wanted it to be
open for business
unless there was a change and that so
that's what they did um we just want to
have a say whether it's opt in or op out
one is a little bit more cumbersome opt
out's more cumbersome but nonetheless
it's a say and during this me memor um
moratorium period um it gives towns and
cities across the state an opportunity
to go ahead and oped out during this
period of time so I think that's fine
it'll work out fine um there were a
number of points that come up uh this is
a bipartisan Bill we were able to get
local and Statewide uh bipartisan
support and really appreciate it because
this is not a partisan issue um I think
everybody wants to make sure that we
keep government at the lowest element
possible there was a point that was
brought up about having an incentive for
to play by the the rules and have this
re this come up every three years and
that's not our intent that the towns
would do that every three years we did
come up with the protection for the 14
existing casinos and the five in the
pipeline which unfortunately includes
Littleton uh but Littleton supports the
bill anyway even though it won't really
protect Littleton but here I am in and
advocating for you to go ahead and pass
this because it is good for all of the
towns and all of the Cities
so in terms of the every threeyear thing
I I don't think it's important that the
towns do this every three years I think
the Lottery Commission and such can
regulate the industry well and if
somebody's not adhering to their
regulations that they can do the kind of
things they do put somebody on probation
and such like that we don't need to
involve the towns in a popular vote on
that
one um generating Revenue how much
revenue do we want to generate from
casinos and who's effective
um the Charities there's the commission
will be looking at that and the previous
commission looked at it very intensely
of who benefits and what should be
looked at in terms of charitable
distribution but you know if you had a
casino in every single town in every
city in the state you had six of them in
every single bigger Town um you would
really make less money because it just
wouldn't be as interesting to the
consumer and so there there's really not
a need to have everywhere have every
place have as many casinos as possible I
I don't think that that is the factor
involved in generating renov revenue on
this there is a lot of Revenue coming in
and the the numbers are staggering the
the one that would be coming to
Littleton is projected to be
um I call it draining uh $17 million out
of the local economy that's my
perspective I'm entitled to that but in
any case uh around the state there's
many many um dollars that are going into
the profits and there's a good chunk
that goes to the the the Charities 35%
on certainly of the games and other
games it's much slower but in the end um
that's a big piece of money to the
Charities and we're hoping that will get
um providing see in and
there are some things in the amendment
that are important um Alicia is going to
speak to that and I really appreciate
her work on this even before coming to
your committee and she's been working
with our sponsor uh representative Bill
Boyd and uh has come up with a couple of
uh things she she'd like to move some of
the sections before the notwithstanding
part uh which is fine with us um another
thing is to make sure that the the years
that are in your copy of this that says
2 years for the abandonment sentence to
kick in that wasn't our intent we
understand that a Cino once it's
invested there's a lot of money put into
these facilities and to have that
jeopardized in just for a
two-year problem in in building or or
Staffing and such that's not fair to the
business and so um the first you have
two and two right now it should be five
and 10 that 5 years of Abandonment 10
years if they never built that that
would come up eligible to come up for a
vote again that's one tiny little piece
that
Littleton takes some help in is that
maybe they'll just never build it in
Littleton and then 15 years from now
we'll be able to get ourselves a a
little vote anyway that's that's our um
there's been a lot of effort on this and
it it had very Cooperative people
working on both houses as well as all
sides of the aisle and the lobbyists and
um the citizens so I very much
appreciate
questions seeing none thank you very
thank you hello again thank you Mr
chairman members of the committee I'm
Alicia Preston I'm here representing the
New Hampshire Charle gaming operators
Association uh we are here in support of
this legislation I know it's been
something that has been being worked on
for um over a year and a request that
many lawmakers have wanted uh We've
enjoyed working with the stakeholders in
this along with the sponsor um we do
have a few tweaks to to this bill that
we've requested
representative boydd their minor
language move pieces around nothing that
affects the substance of the bill I
believe um representative voy and we are
all on the same page I haven't seen a
copy of that Amendment yet I'm not sure
if it's ready so I can't weigh in on it
specifically um if you want me to get
into details that's fine otherwise I
think when that Amendment comes it will
reflect the minor concerns we have on
bill representa elme thank you I don't
know who asked this question of so I'm
going to ask you uh while they were
moving into Lebanon they had to get
approval to move from the Central
District where they were mostly
affecting poor people and disabled
people um to um route four which is the
main Corridor between east and west from
New Hampshire through
Vermont um and which was already pretty
crowded and they um and they went before
the planning board and they provided a
traffic report which was based on the
city of Kean which if you've been to
Kean Keane is a smallish City surrounded
by large amounts of land where the inter
the the major roads go
through so um it wasn't exactly
comparable with the most crowded part of
Route 4 in
Lebanon um and they asked them to
provide yet another traffic report and
they came back with from what I
understood essentially the same thing
and they asked them for another and it
was pointed out that they were going to
be violating I think its statute by uh
undo
re
uh uh
recalcitrant uh by not approving the
thing in a appropriate amount of time
and they gave in and approved it and I
am wondering if there is anything
Lebanon can do if it turns out it's just
opened it's a little hard to tell how
much further traffic disruption we're
going to have in that area it's just
below where I come out of my Road um and
um if there is further traffic
disruption if there's
any any right that Lebanon has to get
some kind of compensation or
whatever so I'm not as familiar with
that specific situation as obviously you
are um certainly this bill wouldn't
address that this bill would strictly I
mean it's already a grandfathered in
facility in Lebanon and there is nothing
in this bill that addresses what those
concerns are um as for compensation from
the facility I'm just not familiar with
what the rules regulations and approvals
in Lebanon
are yeah well I don't think Lebanon has
much choice but uh unless there's
something in the statute somewhere
that does something about
that thank you any other
questions seeing none thank you very
you I now have uh bro Des
here was there anyone else that wanted
bill
okay all right well he's not here and no
one else wants to speak then I will
737 what do we do if he was didn't
actually speak you still keep this i t
you yeah make sense he didn't actually
yeah he did is that the right
one what bill is that yeah that's 68
that's the one I work
on we don't have 7 oh it's still there
signing the next hearing starts at two
e
okay the time being
203 I'm going to open the public hearing
on HB 635
and
uh ask representative corkran to
introduce the
bill howdy thank you for having me so um
fundamentally this is a bill about who
and who does not get nonprofit status in
New Hampshire um and it's a small
administrative change and uh this is my
summary but you know just
extemporaneously I'm going to move it to
the front which is nonprofit status is
not a right of any entity there are many
pro-social groups in the State uh
hanford's brings us food Auto fire Honda
sells me uh cars but they uh do not get
nonprofit status the state chooses to
give nonprofit status as a tool of
public policy to achieve ends that it
wishes to
achieve there's a vast powerful and
extremely well-funded network of
organizations that profit by settling un
assemblable foreigners in New Hampshire
they call themselves nonprofits but that
phrase merely means that there are no
shareholders the profits that they make
are instead distributed to employees or
retained by settling skilled foreigners
in New Hampshire they create massive
negative externalities Carnage really
and they get paid and paid well for
doing it I can think of no better way to
illustrate this then by looking over the
testimony that was submitted to the
committee last night by the New
Hampshire immigrant rights Network who
is this and who are some of the
co-signers of the letter we can find out
by find pulling the form uh 990s from
the IRS the short answer is that these
firms are big very big it's important to
realize when looking over these
financial statements that these NOS are
funded in two ways by government G
grants directly um or uh indirectly
laundered through other Nos and also by
program revenues which is just a
different way is saying by government
grants program revenues is where the
government either New Hampshire or at
the federal level says to an NGO we're
going to pay you effectively $300 for
every person that you you know provide
service X or Y or Z
for and so excuse me going through some
of the uh constituent parts of the New
Hampshire immigrant rights Network we
see USA hello with revenues of 1 million
Grant State organizing project with
revenues of 1 million uh The
International Institute of New England
with revenues of 17.5 million the CEO
Jeffrey Felman makes quar million dollar
a year the national immigration law
Center 24 million a year most of it from
tax money the executive director makes
300K a year the COO 300K a year the CCO
300K a year uh I'm going to do another
five or six but not the 70 or 80 that I
could American friends service committee
$40 million they have redacted the CEO
pay Catholic Charities New Hampshire 4
million $45 million with a CEO salary of
400,000 a year entria Care Alliance now
this is a very interesting one it is a
web of 13 different
ngos and they all share an interlocking
directorship they all have some of the
same officers they pay funds back and
forth to each other entry Care Alliance
9 million CEO Angela boville $400,000 a
year ENT Community Care Incorporated 9
million year in tax dollars CEO Angela
bouville $400,000 a cental community
services Lutheran Home of Southbury Fair
Havens etc
etc the total amount that the asentria
Care Alliance is getting from tax
dollars is uh I've seen various numbers
the lowest number is $120 million a year
if you add all of these up there is a
NGO uh Network that is getting paid on
the order of $250 million a year mostly
to deal with settling foreigners in and
around New Hampshire this money all
comes from taxpayer Pockets or the vast
majority of it does and as I said some
of it is by direct government grants
some of it uh is indirect through other
Nos and some of it is by government
grants that are per uh person
fees there's a question um you know a
lot of this is not explicitly said to be
for illegals it is for you know refugees
or immigrants or new granite Staters
Etc um
and if you dig into the various websites
of these firms that are getting this
government largess and then getting
nonprofit status so that they're not
taxed on it um
they are a little bit koi about exactly
who they're serving some of them uh you
know first of all no one is going to use
the word illegal immigrant uh even
though that is the legal term uh they
will use other terms but um they also
talk about some of the services they
provide and uh let's see the national
immigration law Center which is part of
this Coalition uh brags on its website
about how it has engaged in programs to
allow illegals to enter and stay in the
US and how they work to uh defend their
status and engage with the government
and Lobby uh for changes in policy so
that enforcement actions are not taken
the letter that you all received last
night from the New Hampshire immigrant
rights network is worth reading
carefully it first engages in an
irrelevant and diversionary tactic by
saying quote this unnecessary Bill
appears rooted in the misconception that
non-citizens even undocumented ones are
given public benefits this is an
absolutely false claim legal aliens are
eligible for many taxpayer provided
benefits including not just Wick which
is what welfare is called but also all
the services provided by the nhn members
such as housing food Furniture
Transportation legal assistance and more
which are paid for with taxpayer money
via grants and program revenues which
again is taxpayer
money nhn and its letter then goes on to
say that it is lawful to provide
services to New Hampshire residents some
of whom may be illegal this is uh claim
is an attempt to mutay the waters excuse
me this bill does not argue that
providing services to illegal aliens is
itself illegal this bill merely notes
that nonprofit status is not a right but
a benefit that the government of New
Hampshire extends to certain
organizations if they are engaged in
certain pro-social activities as defined
in RSA 292 colon 1 RSA 292 extends the
status to organizations that maintain
cemeteries but not to organizations that
sell televisions it extends the status
to organizations that plant trees but
not to organizations that arrange cars
races nonprofit status is a policy tool
of the people of New Hampshire and it
may be extended or withdrawn to achieve
the goals that the people of New
Hampshire wish to uh
achieve another thing that the nhn
letter says is that it would be
implausible for them to make sure that
the people they serve uh are legal this
is a claim but it's not a claim that I
uh agree with ever verify is a free
service offered by the US government
that confirms the legal status of a
person eify is required to be used by
all Pro uh for-profit companies if I uh
am running a lawn care service and I
want to hire people I'm required to
verify that they're citizens or
otherwise eligible for employment uh and
legal status in the United States the
website explains that this takes 3 to 5
Seconds nhn says in its letter this bill
would Place New Hampshire nonprofit
organizations in the precarious position
of making determinations about
immigration status of the individuals
and families seeking
assistance are we to believe that
through 5c verification process that
every single for-profit employer in New
Hampshire uses is impossible for firms
that make their profits not from
providing benefits to the public but
from receiving government grants the
letter concludes with the claim this
bill is designed to Shield the provision
of the services to non-citizens this is
the logical fallacy of appeal to motive
and the claim is incorrect this bill is
designed not to uh chill the provision
of services to non-citizens many of whom
are legally allowed to reside in New
Hampshire but to chill the provision of
services to illegal aliens who
definitely do not
I want to talk about the effects of
importing foreigners to New
Hampshire excuse me um nhn talks about
the good works of the New Hampshire ngi
uh NOS I'd like to ex examine the claim
uh kinds of the NOS that they're
composed of and if these are
supported um for most of my information
on the effect of uh bringing forers to
New Hampshire I uh am referencing a
report published by UNH this report is
the the refugee resettlement in New
Hampshire Pathways to building community
and I want to note that this studied uh
primarily refugees um which is not the
same as in legal status as far as
illegal immigrants but is the best data
that is available on settling
non-americans in New Hampshire this
report was written by Nina Glick
Schiller PhD uh Professor UNH Jerry and
bores UNH Molly messenger UNH and some
statistics and I want to point out this
is a report that is bragging about the
integration success that uh these uh
types of immigrants have achieved and so
this is the Steelman the you know let's
round every number up let's put a
positive spin on everything and so I'm
not looking at the Pat Buchanan
anti-immigration fund I'm not you know
quoting David Duke or anything
insane page two 62% have not graduated
high school page two 33% speak zero
English page two low-wage workers page
42 largely illiterate page page 11 68%
have no family or friends
rootless uh speaking to goals of chain
migration page 12 quoting one person the
highest thing I can think of is to try
to bring my family members here page 27
top three goals of the population
include bringing their family to the
US one of the goals is public
assistance page 15 table four um percent
of the population currently using
Section 8 housing 26% percent using Wick
that is welfare 30% percent using
Medicaid 34% percent using food pantries
38% percent on food stamps
53% um at least 90% of this population
has at some point been either on food
stamps indor Medicaid page 19 25% of
them are unemployed of those who do work
many of them were not working
full-time um the study goes on to say uh
this is from sort of the activist
perspective at UNH and this is uh with
overlapping personnel and um goals as
the NGS um that one of the uh problems
is that there is not enough federal or
state housing benefits and we need to
extend to
that um some of the problems that the
you know again generally pro-immigration
report noted is that refugees have a
complaint they complain that there are
laws against public drinking and against
public
congregation um also on page 24 the
report also notes that there is a
problem with the American legal system
because we enforce rules against uh
beating children and this is hard to
reconcile with uh some foreign cultures
quote immigrants believe that the
lessons contributed in schools about
children not being beaten contributed to
undermining parental Authority they
believe that the lack of respect for
elders is a far greater offense than the
physical punishment of
children um another problem with the uh
immigration process and the you know
kinds of people that the NOS are
bringing in
is that we are importing ethnic
rivalries on page 25 of this report they
talk about tensions that exist overseas
that are being brought here as members
of competing tribes are settled in the
same place um and then finally I'd like
to wrap up with a few local news stories
about some of the enrichment that these
NGS are helping to deliver to conquered
uh patch.com um two days ago um has a
story um let's see Regis babo
has escaped a felony burglary and sexual
assault charges due to a plea deal he is
now accused of stealing a Honda Accord
during the past four years he's been
arrested or summoned in 32 criminal
cases and one civil stalking case
according to police records previously
charged with felonious sexual assault
indecent exposure gross ludus burglary
domestic violence criminal threat
disobeying an officer disorderly conduct
driving after revocation simple assault
criminal threatening criminal mischief
theft receiving stolen property DUI
resisting arrest breach of bail warrants
as well as driving possession of tobacco
possession of
alcohol um another news story from a few
days before that uh three Chinese
Nationals in New Hampshire plead guilty
to stealing millions of dollar and Apple
products via gift card scam another
patch.com article from a bit before that
conquered Heights man arrested on sexual
assault um criminal mischief charges
Nado turri Kiva was accused of
assaulting an attempting to rape a woman
after being accused of previous rapes in
the same complex
and I'm about to hit the summary so I
apologize for the very long-winded thing
um the motivation behind a lot of the
NOS doing the resettlement work uh work
where they you know are dealing with
lots of populations and they you know
assert that you know they can't tell if
any of these are illegal and they
certainly don't want to check because
they're getting paid per person that
they provide these Services too um at
least one of the upsides is that we're
achieving diversity and there have been
many articles New York Times and other
places talking about you know a lot of
places are achieving these great
successes but sadly a few States like
New Hampshire are lagging behind we do
not have the diversity that uh the rest
of the country uh is sometimes blessed
with and I want to quote from a New York
Times article uh 2007 entitled the
downside of diversity and again uh I
challenged myself to uh bring up
statistics only that came from the left
side of the aisle not from you know
anything questionable and you know
strange and rightwing uh I will
uh constrain myself to only quoting from
The New York Times it has become
increasingly popular to speak of racial
and ethnic diversity as a Civic strength
from Multicultural festivals to
pronouncements from political leaders
the message is the same our differences
make us stronger but a massive new study
based on detailed interviews with nearly
30,000 people has concluded just the
opposite Harvard political scientist
Robert putam famous for his book bowling
alone on declining Civic engagement has
found that the greater the diversity in
a community the fewer people vote and
the less they volunteer the less they
give to charity and work on community
projects in the most diverse communities
neighbors trust one another about half
as much as they do in the most
homogenous settings the study the
largest ever on Civic engagement in
America found that virtually all
measures of Civic Health are lower in
more diverse settings quote the extent
of the effect is shocking end quote says
Scott page University of Michigan
political
scientist this study to the best of my
research has never been refuted or
modified with any other studies so
speaking directly to the bill and
summing up there's nothing in this bill
that stops any of these NOS from dealing
with uh refugees designated by the US
government there's nothing to stop them
from dealing with um first generation
immigrants or second IM generation
immigrants and there is actually nothing
that stops them from providing services
to illegal aliens we are not policing
that they can do whatever they want they
can uh open food pantries to illegal
aliens they can provide them uh
Apartments the only thing it does it
says the state of New Hampshire the
government of the State of New Hampshire
is tasked with figuring out what our
social priorities are and we use our tax
policy to implement these social
priorities you can do lots of things you
can run a dog adoption center you can do
community gardening you can have a uh
little Library all of those things get
nonprofit status but if you uh engage in
the active settlement of illegal aliens
in New Hampshire you're allowed to do
that it's not our job to stop you it's
just that we are not going to reward you
with nonprofit status thank thank you
for your time and I welcome any
this you have two separate definitions
of business
Enterprise which contradict each
other
um that's line three and then again on
line
19 um you
don't Define what engaged in means or
attempting to engage in I and your
discussion of the impact of illegal
aliens was correct but it didn't apply
to how this bill is going to be
implemented or operated
or or what it
does um your definition of illegal
immigrant is
interesting although I don't think since
there's no such thing as an illegal
immigrant under federal law you can't
use federal law to Define it there are
illegal
aliens under the code but there's no
immigrant what is um question ask well
this is constitutional questions as the
Constitutional question is with the the
way this language is set up and under
our rules as you know the vice chair's
task with that
job um take a society like uh St Vincent
the Paul which does a great deal of good
work in
providing all sorts of services to
individuals that need service their
Charter as a religious organization says
you come to the door you seek food and
I'm going to give it to
you but your
definition would seemingly point of
order is there a question it's a
constitutional
question would seemingly
violate the Constitutional ban on
interference in religion respectfully I
disagree um the society is absolutely
free to do anything it wants nothing in
them except they would be taxed to do so
there are other religiously mandated
activities that are exposed to taxation
I
believe do you have a followup no thank
you okay represent Al
me thank you I also find it hard to know
where to begin first um I was reading
through this um immigrant rights Network
that we got the other day uh and I was
reading through it as you were listing a
whole bunch of stuff that doesn't seem
to be in here and
about for 75% of of these are not
organizations they are
individuals I know a few of those
individuals not many because they don't
seem to have come to Western New
Hampshire very often
um and the bill is full of things like
like um attempting to engage in in tting
to tending to provide intending to
provide uh should be known uh that are
things that is go are going to be very
hard to prove if you're trying to say if
if you've got a a bounty hunter who it
which is also a trigger term uh that are
uh are is going after anybody that he
can find that he thinks has been talking
with somebody that that he should know
is an illegal immigrant do not believe
that anything might Bill criminalizes
speaking to an illegal
immigrant what it does is to tax tax the
organization that they belong to if they
belong to an organization I don't know
what it does if they don't uh
uh but and then on top of that could I
ask you why you think that the
Department of Revenue Administration
would be
capable
of running a bunch of B bounty
hunters um I believe that I said that
this uh gives them the authority to do
that if they want to and there is no
requirement that they do
so it's the Department of Revenue
Administration does not have the
capacity or duty to do these things
unless you put it there and we vote for
it I'm happy to answer any
questions any other questions yes
represent
you talk about taking away nonprofit
status from people who are providing
services to people who are here
illegally that's correct yes I'm
wondering if you would have the same
perspective of
organizations that refuse to provide
services to people who are here legally
who may be brown skinned or black
skinned or yellow
skinned but whoever the provider may be
might say well I don't think you're here
legally and because that person doesn't
happen to have papers with him or her
that they would simply refuse to provide
services respectfully there's nothing in
this bill that mentions or alludes to
skin color um if an illegal immigrant uh
from Iceland is here it would
criminalize that and if a uh legal
citizen has you know my best friends
Fred is from Nigeria now he's an
American citizen but if he wasn't you
know uh so as an American citizen it is
and should be perfectly legal to provide
him services so I I would strongly
reject uh the the sort of imputation
that there is something racist uh in
this bill my apologies may I revise that
question sure if anyone from any country
of any color skin who was here legally
and happened not to have papers with
them proving that went to get services
and was turned down because the provider
organization said I don't believe you
are here legally would you likewise say
that organization needs to have its
nonprofit status
removed um I I think I'm being asked
about a question of if a different Bill
were proposed what would I think of that
bill uh I have not read the text of that
bill and I don't have an opinion on it
um but again uh I I want to call out
that the way you phrased the question
was if they did not have papers on them
uh nothing in here is saying that anyone
needs to check papers uh there is a
federal e verify program every
for-profit corporation and there are two
kinds of Corporations there are
for-profit corporations and there are
nonprofit corporations um I've run you
know several small uh for-profit
corporations and we have to go through
paperwork that takes a few seconds punch
in some data hear from the government
that yes they're here legally they can
work
um and so this is not putting any extra
burden on NOS uh it is merely saying
please take the same three seconds that
takes everyone else is done I have
another question thank you represent B
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question so uh I have two friends
from uh South Africa can you tell me
what color they are I have no
idea do you know that Elon Musk is from
South Africa I
do follow up so how many illegal aliens
illegal immigrants or whatever they are
whatever the term analogy is I I don't
know anymore I'm confused just by this
conversation how many have been
resettled here in the conquered General
New Hampshire area whatever the specific
question is how many illegals and I do
not know um and part of the answer is we
have these NOS who are tasked with
providing Services uh they get paid per
person um but because no one is asking
them to collect this data and no one is
asking them to even run ever verify you
know I don't know if there are three or
you know 30,000 and that's part of the
problem last follow what you know if the
Brazilian murderer that was picked up on
the Sea Coast was illegal legal had
papers I I do not know and I also don't
know what degree of services he was
provided by any of the NGS uh affected
by this thank you representative spar
um are you familiar with the immigration
nationality act I've heard the name but
I'm not a lawyer so I'll defer to your
characterization of it it it prohibits
individuals from concealing shielding or
harboring un unauthorized individuals
who come into and remain in the United
States under the law it's a criminal
offense punishable by a fine or
imprisonment for any person so there are
mechanisms and there's enforcement or
the mechanisms for the enforcement of
illegal immigrants um do feel that your
bill is uh unnecessary and that that no
I do not because again this bill is not
about directing the New Hampshire State
Police to find illegals it is not about
uh communicating with ice and helping to
deport them this is a bill that has to
do with the administration of the State
of New Hampshire specifically their tax
code uh uh I don't have the RSA in front
of me anymore but we have very carefully
structured our uh tax code so that you
achieve nonprofit status you know again
there are corporations and corporations
do a lot of stuff some corporations
provide food and they're called Catholic
Charities other corporations provide
food and they're called horts we've
decided to privilege one of these forms
of Corporations if they engage in
certain pro-social acts as determined by
the New Hampshire government and uh this
bill is just about thinking about what
we actually consider pro-social and what
we don't the F uh these corporations
that do the e verifi that's to hire
correct uh people right yes are you
saying these nonprofits like as you
mentioned the Haner versus a Catholic
organization they're hiring people to
give them food no I'm not uh I mean
obviously they do but I don't think
that's the point of your question um
what I'm saying is that the
determination of legal status does not
require spinning up any additional
infrastructure that infrastructure is
already in place it's provided by the
federal government it's free and it
takes 3 to five
seconds to hire someone correct no to
verify their status to be legally Pres
in the United States which is used for
purposes uh
Roser thank you Mr chairman toward the
end of your presentation you mentioned
some uh cases where people who were here
illegally had committed some crimes some
of them pretty
horrific every bit of research that I
have
found indicates that immigrants committ
commit crimes at significantly lower
rates as a group not talking about the
individuals that all of us get up in
arms
about
yet I'm wondering based on that should
we be saying that anybody who commits
crimes should that be a metric for
refusing
Services uh let me first start out by
questioning the premise uh you said that
you uh that every study that you've
looked at says that immigrants uh commit
crimes at lower than the standard rate
I'm also familiar with that claim I have
engaged in extensively with one
researcher from the KO Institute named
Alex nashta uh Alex has written several
white papers about how immigrants are
you know so much not just as uh Good As
Americans on various metrics but so much
better and one of his claims was exactly
that that they've committed uh far less
crimes far fewer crimes um but I dug
into uh the footnotes here and um I
tracked down where he was getting his
data from and turns out that the
statistic that has widely been shared
does not actually analyze what it
purports to analyze it looks at the
number of people who are incarcerated
and as we all know from recent news
events um many times when people commit
crimes they are given a court date um
and if you are given a court date and
then disappear you will never be
convicted and you will never be
incarcerated so uh actually it turns out
that immigrants do commit crimes of All
Sorts at higher r rates than Americans
um it's just that you have to be careful
that you're not using selection bias to
only look at the ones who end up serving
prison sentences I agree with that and
disagree with your conclusion thank you
represent elme thank you I'm wondering
what data do you have to back up the
number of illegal immigrants who commit
crimes um I do not have this they have
data but of a subset which is something
you are using before right uh they
um I've never heard of a survey that
managed to get to all of the people who
had had were in the United States as
illegal immigrants and not yet uh given
Asylum dates and things like that um
who were um uh were committing
crimes I'm sorry I didn't quite proce CE
the question what what is your your data
source right um this investigation is
something that I dug into a year or two
ago I don't have that on hand but uh
again the focus of this bill is not
coordinating with ice it's not deporting
people it's not saying that illegal
immigrants uh commit crimes this bill is
about what types of Corporations the
state of New Hampshire chooses uh to
extend nonprofit status
to representative duet
just to that question I just heard by
virtue of them being illegal
immigrants Crossing into this country
illegally by
definition would that not mean that 100%
of the illegal immigrants are law
Breakers I agree with you so the answer
is
yes okay um seeing no more questions
just to let the committee know I've got
uh 10 10 pink cards so 10 10 people who
want to speak
um so next I
have we'll ask representative McFarlin
up and uh you we're it looks like most
people we put down fairly short amount
of time um two you put down two minutes
representative so
go ahead thank you Mr chairman good
afternoon Mr chairman honorable members
I'm representative Donald McFarland from
Orange I thank you for the opportunity
to testify here on House Bill 635 this
testimony represents My Views and the
views and interests of my constituents
in graph 18 my testimony is not made on
behalf of any private employer nor
should it be construed to represent the
employers I think in in what we've just
heard from the prime sponsor uh some of
those remarks were
specious and I am troubled by the
language of the bill nevertheless I'm in
front of you to support the
bill the intent of the bill is a is a
solid and strong one the rationale
behind permitting and providing tax
benefit to nonprofit organizations at
both the New Hampshire level at the
state level and under the federal laws
with 501c3 designations and so forth is
fundamentally to encourage charitable
religious educational and public service
activities that benefit
society and while representative
elberger may be asking us
questions about immigrants I put it to
you that we have to be very clear here
this is not about immigrants this is
about illegal immigrants illegal aliens
specifically as representative ery
said I have looked at those studies that
you reference Ed in some
detail like uh the prior speaker I don't
have those facts and figures at my
fingertips but you you may detect from
my accent that I have an interest in
this and I satisfied Myself by looking
at those studies that there was some
Merit I'm not saying it was absolutely
clear lies damn lies and statistics
right but but it seemed to be the case
that in fact immigrants are incarcerated
at a lower rate and do commit uh
violations of law at a lower rate than
the rest of of the US citizenry that is
not true when it comes to illegal aliens
not only have they as was stated
committed a violation of law in Crossing
into the country in many
cases but in in the aggregate they are
more prone to causing societal
problems it is not a benefit to New
Hampshire to encourage and support the
presence of illegal aliens here in New
Hampshire and for us to say and let's be
narrow about this for us to say in this
bill if we can get the language right we
do not think that we should
be benefiting an organization that we
should be supporting an organization
with these nonprofit designations and
tax
benefits that is AC against the
interests of our society I think that is
something that is appropriate for the
state legislature to do there was a
question I think it was rep bar that
asked about do we have satisfactory
legislation at the federal level and yes
we indeed have a bunch of federal
statutes I would cite at8 USC
1324 which makes it a felony to Aid and
abet these illegal
aliens that applies to their
employers that applies to to people
giving them sanctuary in other
respects is that federal statute
sufficient it certainly hasn't been over
the last number of years maybe it will
start to be employed a little bit more
under the new
Administration but when we ask ourselves
what should we be doing as a state
legislature and what can we do as a
state legislature I think that even
though his language may not be perfect
representative corran's idea is a strong
one and I would strongly encourage this
committee to contemplate whatever
amendments might be needed so that you
can support this bill and move it ought
to pass uh thank you and I Y to
questions representative
YY thank you representative I enjoy
listening to you as you know we've had
that discussion
uh would in your opinion would this uh
if we modify the language to upon
conviction of or by
somebody would that be a more effective
and judicious application of this
particular
penalty I I think in answering that let
let me say this I first of all I think
it's absurd to say that one of these
organizations could use eify eify is not
designed to assess who is here legally
it's designed to assess who is able
lawfully to work and those are two
different issues we've also heard in
other committees that he verifi I has
some operational difficulties such that
I believe the labor committee voted itl
on a bill to require e verify for all
employers so I think to your
question it is difficult to come up and
I I believe you said this yourself it is
difficult to come up with some of the
mechanisms for enforcement it is
mechanisms whereby the Charities uh and
the organizations themselves would be
able to make the these discernments on
an individual caseby casee basis I would
say to you first of all that I think
that your suggestion is an interesting
one that I might well support I would
also say to you that there is a
difference between picking out one
individual exception to the rule as a
basis to deny nonprofit status and
looking at the prevailing circumstances
and and seeing what is uh no longer just
the AUD exception here or there where
somebody didn't come with their
paperwork and what has turned into a
routine and major part of that
organization's business and we know that
in this state there are multiple
organizations that are routinely and and
as a very significant part of their
activities focusing on individuals who I
I don't dislike this language where it
says should know rather than merely
knowingly who should very well know that
they are focused on illegal
aliens other
DWI hi I'm Nathan DWI I'm a citizen of
New Hampshire I I live at uh 211 Valley
West way in
Manchester uh hillsbor County and I'm
here to speak on behalf of Bill 6 uh
35 um I don't have huge amount to say on
this I'm just
somewhat an I think Paul is a little
that's too strong but it's the word that
comes to mind that we are currently
spending money
to help
out uh we are
currently
through uh new hampire where're spending
money and giving that money to uh
nonprofits who then use that money to
facilitate illegal immigration when we
still have problems for example paying
for schools we have and a variety of
other problems I'd prefer that money be
spent in new Hamp uh for New Hampshire
citizens and for people who who legally
live here uh you my time or questions
thank you any questions seeing none
thank
Valentini hi my name is Justin Valentini
I live at 82 School Street right here in
conquer ladies and Gentlemen We Gather
here today to support House Bill 635 a
bill that reflects our commitment to
dignity and fairness for all in our
modern era it is not just unacceptable
but morally repugnant to continue
practices that Echo the darkest parts of
our history bringing poor illegal aliens
to our state solely for the purpose of
Labor is nothing short of modern-day
slavery just as slaveholders 200 years
ago exploited human beings for economic
gain we must recognize that using
immigration policy to fill labor
shortages is a continuation of that same
dehumanizing
Legacy House Bill 635 is not about not
just about policy it is about restoring
integrity and Humanity to our
system let's talk about the
organizations that profit from this
cycle of
exploitation the NOS that claim to
support the resettlement of these
individuals it is crucial to examine who
benefits from this system the leadership
in these organizations is predominantly
white and there's a clear Financial
incentive at play they are not driven by
altruism but by profit capitalizing on
the plight of the vulnerable to secure
funds and
influence we must ask ourselves why are
these jobs not filled by those who
advocate for this system the answer is
starkly clear these are jobs they
themselves would never
do House Bill 635 aims to stop the
taxpayer funding of this structure of
human trafficking and profit
hearing supporting this bill means that
we are committed to breaking the chains
of exploitation that have been reformed
but not
eradicated this bill is just the first
step to stopping the flow it's about
rethinking our approach to labor dignity
and human rights by passing this bill we
take a stand against practices that are
reminiscent of our past we affirm that
every person regardless of origin
deserves to live free from
exploitation let us choose a future
where our actions reflect our values of
equality respect and opportunity for all
thank
you thank you represent
yri you happen to have our that in
written form that could be entered into
the record and
distributed y thank
you representative elberger thank you Mr
chair have you ever met any of the
people working in the organizations
you're talking
about do you believe all of them
followup do you believe that all of them
there
are not there because they believe in
what they're doing it sounded like you
were saying that at the beginning of
your testimony I believe they have a
financial incentive that creates a
represent
elme do you have any information that
indicates that any of these people are
benefiting uh
illegally by a fin this financial
incentive you're talking
about benefiting illegally no I have
benefiting from uh from bringing in
immigrants and
uh helping them to find jobs do they
have any Financial relationship with uh
the companies that they are or Farms
that they are getting uh jobs
from not entirely sure I understand the
question but I will say that they have
an incentive in so far as they are paid
through salaries and they have I mean if
you just think about it right if you are
are an organization that wants to
resettle people here you have every
incentive to want to resettle more and
more people right there there like
there's no like their job is done once
they hit some certain cap so they will
grow okay uh yes who's paying those
organizations some cases they are
taxpayer funded okay and other
sure okay seeing no more questions thank
Dre hey good afternoon my name's John
dman uh I'm a longtime resident of uh
New Hampshire I uh my family and I
currently reside in pum and uh I'm up
here today because I am also a strong
supporter of HP
and uh I want to say that uh I think
after I thought I knew what we were
going to be talking about when I came in
here this this afternoon uh in my mind
we're not talking about individuals
we're not talking about policy at the
federal government level I think what
we're talking about is the tax status of
companies doing business in the state of
New Hampshire and specifically Nos and
whether they should retain a tax exemp
status or not and many of us here today
are going to tell you we don't think
they
should uh I would also tell you and just
listening to everyone this afternoon we
really have no transparency in the state
of New Hampshire over this topic for
example uh how is this program managed
who's in who's in charge how many people
fall into this program through the NGO
organizations come to New
Hampshire who's making all those
decisions what's the purpose of the
refugee
Affairs uh uh division under the
governor what do they do I would tell
you in my brief look at all this what
they do is they serve as nothing more
than a facilitator between the
Department of State and NOS that are
doing business here in New Hampshire so
uh foreign
resettlement is Big Business and uh a
lot of you a lot of us have talked about
what are we call what are we calling
this I've heard everything from illegal
aliens uh undocumented
immigrants uh and every variation of
that theme I think what we're talking
about the correct term is and like a lot
of people don't like to talk about it is
it's illegal aliens that's the correct
term that gets you to the level of
fidelity you need but we're not talking
about the individual we're talking about
the
corporation uh so this is a uh the
business model here is you get paid I
Believe by the uh the ngos get paid for
each individual they bring through the
system the more individuals you bring
the more you get paid how much is that I
have no idea I don't know if any of you
know how much that money is each year
but I think it's worth taking a look at
uh long-term cost we're talking really
about uh the tax status but there's also
long-term cost to the state of New
Hampshire the uh the NOS are in what I
call phase one 60 to 90 days and after
that a lot of people that are in this
program shift over to uh uh various uh
uh social welfare programs for the long
term and they become invisible to us uh
so I believe that these NGO
organizations do operate as a business
in the area that we're talking about and
so I strongly support the bill and I
think this bill is really just phase one
I think this bill would go a long way to
making the program visible to the people
of New Hampshire and to you so we can
have a common view of the battlefield
here so when we're talking about this
program what's the size and scope of
this program I don't know I'm not sure
any of you know uh and I just say that
because that's kind of how it is but
from a tax status I think we're talking
a lot of money I see no reason why these
individual organizations shouldn't pay
their fair share to use an overuse term
uh when it comes to uh taxable status so
I thank you very much and I'll take your
question questions if you have any
representa elmy thank you I am very
confused it sounds like you're talking
about the legal immigration that the
federal government has been paying for
to place people
into uh Manchester in particular but a
number of different places well we're
talking about the in New Hampshire
you're talking about some hidden single
program of NOS no I'm I'm not talking
about the uh I didn't come here today to
talk about the legal or illegal status
of immigrants I came to talk about the
uh the business status of NGS doing
Hampshire thank you any other
next I have D Bros
dlav
slos good afternoon my name is as you
can hear by my name I am a child of
immigrants in fact I'm a child of
refugees family came over here in 1979
life I have a
question we have a budget deficit here
in the state of New Hampshire
I'm from salsburg New Hampshire just up
the
road our school right now is proposing a
warrant article for $2 million to fill a
budget deficit why are these
organizations tax exempt they're clearly
profitable the people that work for them
clearly are making plenty of money the
incentives are all
there everybody's I was just at my uh
Town's uh budget hearing yesterday
everybody's complaining about taxes
local taxes Rising mostly because of the
load of additional people coming into
communities why are we supporting more
people more immigration illegal
immigration into the state of New
Hampshire where our property values have
jumped 70% in the past 5 years where our
population you jumped 200,000 in the
past five
years and we're supporting this somehow
where our seniors can't pay their house
taxes and they might get kicked out of
this and we're allocating money and
we're basically taking money off the
table for these organizations to do
whatever they will with that money and
yet there's a budget deficit in the
state budget what's going on thank
afternoon my name is Tyler Richardson
longtime president of New Hampshire I'm
just here to support the bill and say I
don't think we should be incentivizing
this kind of behavior with companies in
our state um previous speaker that was
excellent um you know we shouldn't be
incentivizing bringing people here and
taking up more of our social services
and state fund State funding when we
don't have enough to go around as it
is thank
much next I have
Matt
L afternoon uh my name is Matt leair I
live in stratum and I just want to say
I'm against tax exempt status for
corporations that are involved in human
trafficking because that's really what
this is that's all I have to say okay
Kaufman hi I'm Jeremy Kaufman I'm a
resident of East Manchester where I've
lived for more than a decade uh I
believe this area of the city has
received more of these types of migrants
and Asylum Seekers than any other part
of the State uh to my knowledge several
thousand of these people have been
settled in in Manchester making up a a
substantial percentage of the population
now at least several digit percentage
and a lot of these people are in East
Manchester specifically and so I'm not
going to argue statistics uh or facts
but I can tell you a little bit about
the subjective experience of living in a
place where some of these people are are
coming um and it absolutely does change
the character of the city uh in a way
for the worst um and I'll tell one short
story although I could tell a bunch um
we uh I do these park cleanups with a
group called weart West in in Manchester
we go around we we uh we clean up the
parks and there's a park in East
Manchester that's specifically dirty all
the time and we went out and we cleaned
up we filled up about 10 bags of trash
and the woman uh shows up with her
children this we're mostly done with the
cleanup we gave her kids some some candy
she couldn't speak English and she she
littered the candy wrappers right in
front of us right after we had cleaned
up all the trash and you know that's not
going to show up on your crime stats I
don't know what stats going to show up
that number but but the idea that
somewhere would get a tax deduction to
bring more people like her into East
Manchester like what are we what are we
doing you know so talk to some of the
people in these parts of the City talk
to some of the places where these people
end up and just ask yourself is this
charity work is is this what we want to
subsidize as the government and I would
talk to some of the people who end up
not the NOS who are getting paid who are
making money they can set in their
lobbyist talk to people who who end up
where these people end up because I'm
here for free I don't get paid to do
this you know so talk to some of those
people that's all I'd say thank you
Daves hello everyone uh my name is
Stephen Daves I live in Deerfield I'm
here to um to support the bill um I
think there's a a negative incentive
with encouraging tax exemption for
committing felonies uh just in general
you probably shouldn't do that
especially if you have an opportunity to
uphold the Constitution uh which which
talks about directly naturalization
process you're supposed to follow if you
want to come to this country um and not
it does not talk about specifically
giving tax exempt status to bring people
here illegally um so that's all I want
to test give testimony for if you have
any questions I'll entertain
hi uh Ben hartin live with my family in
Penbrook building in landf 've been New
Hampshire residents for about four years
um in the decade or so after my wife and
I met at MIT we lived in just about
every blue City you can think of across
this country uh for work uh travel all
that and when it came time for us to
settle down and start a family we chose
New Hampshire for a reason it's because
living and working in those cities we've
seen all of the problems uh that come
with uh you know sort of like unfettered
um illegal immigration breakdown of rule
of law Etc we thought about a place that
we wanted to settle down and invest in
Raz our 2 soon to be three children New
Hampshire made sense uh and when I look
at us subsidizing functionally what
we're doing with that nonprofit s
subsidizing people to Aid and abet uh
people who are here illegally just
doesn't make sense to
me thank
next I have
mccy hello my name is Kyle mccy I live
in Dober and I just want to say I don't
support human trafficking and I don't
think that we should support it with our
tax dollars or tax exempt
statuses uh we have so many things that
we need to pay for in this country that
we should not be maxing our credit cards
to bring in illegal immigrants for
non-exempt status that's all I have to
you and the last uh card I have is
Richard
Menard thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee my name is Rick Menard
I'm the executive director of building
community in New Hampshire we're a
private nonprofit based in Manchester we
work Statewide with
refugees and I hadn't intended to
testify today but there's been so much
misunderstanding about Refugee
resettlement and some of the
organizations that work with refugees
that I just wanted to set the record
straight uh Refugee resettlement is a
federal program carefully managed by the
US state department and the US office of
Health and Human Services organizations
like mine have contracts with the state
of New Hampshire to assist those legal
refugees when they're here we don't get
paid per head but we get paid to deliver
services and I get paid uh to run the
organization uh I don't we are not a a
wealthy organization by any means uh but
it's an important and valuable service I
firmly believe that New Hampshire is
better off because of refugee
resettlement here people serve in this
legislature who came as refugees uh and
I'm proud of proud that they were among
the founders of my
organization uh so it's really valuable
to step back and recognize that the only
people bring who in New Hampshire that
I'm aware of who are importing
foreigners under federal government uh
in the form of
refugees uh none of the organizations
that were list Ed in in the sponsors
testimony is to my knowledge are
trafficking in human beings are bringing
in people are being paid to bring in
people or get PA or paid to once they
are here by any public
Source I am not an expert in services to
people without
documentation in fact I know very little
about it we do check our clients
immigration status because we do get
paid by our federal contracts only if
people are here in the first 5 years of
their time in the United States with
with
documentation and so I think most of
what you
see most of what's been talking about
here is based on misunderstandings and
misconceptions uh there are certainly
people in New Hampshire without
documentation it's a separate issue and
I don't know much about the Services
they get or who provides them I imagine
that hospitals take care of them if they
get hit hit by a car I imagine the
churches feed them if they show up at
the food pantry and and I know that
there are people who are trying to
organize them and help them get
citizenship and Asylum and and to live
and work in the United States you can be
the judge of whether that's prudent uh
activity for a
nonprofit I I that's your your
domain uh but I I want you to understand
that um it's frustrating as it is when
somebody throws candy wrappers on the
ground and I man I'd get pissed off too
uh it's not really R A rationale for
adopting this bill I urge you to itl it
I don't think it's well conceived and I
don't think that that the problem of
nonprofit organizations
serving uh the illegals is is a a a
significant financial uh impact on the
state of New Hampshire thank you any
questions seeing none thank
you that's all I have for pink cards is
there anyone else who has not spoken who
wishes to
speak
Travis corkran uh Prime sponsor of the
bill I would just like to thank the
previous testimony for explaining that
NOS can check the legal status of the uh
immigrants that they serve thank
you thank you um we have uh Dr here does
do okay um Jennifer if you come
you and I like all of you so please
don't uh shoot the
messenger Jennifer Ram I'm tax policy
Council for the Department of Revenue
Administration thank you representative
uh thank you um in reading the bill on
page one line 14 and 15 the use of
Consolidated returns is defined in the
United States Internal Revenue code or
in the combin combined reporting is not
uh
permitted that's how you do business
taxes isn't
information General
yes follow up follow so there would be
no way that the state of New Hampshire
could do any tax analysis as to whether
or not the entity was how they were
operating or anything because we don't
collect that data independent of the IRS
records
correct so I'm not entirely certain what
the that language in the bill is
intended to accomplish um if if the
intent of that language is to indicate
that we should be considering whether a
business Enterprise meets the
qualifications in the statute based not
on a Consolidated Enterprise but based
on one individual component of what
would ordinarily be combined reporting
um then I think we could um engage in
that analysis if I'm understanding the
bill
correctly in that case what would be the
cost or could you determine the cost or
an estimate of the cost and add that to
the fiscal note uh so the uh we did not
anticipate that there would be any
additional cost um to administer this
statute over and above our or ordinary
operating costs um with that
understanding of the statute in
mind thank
you any other questions represent
elme yes
um the bill seems
to assuming that you are going to be
responsible for uh accepting
and uh
analyzing I presume
verifying
on any complaints that come in that
there a particular NGO is engaging in
supporting illegal
immigrants
on what would it take to add that to the
the
Dr as we understand the Bill's
responsibility uh with respect to Dr
this would create uh potentially an
additional group of taxpayers uh and we
do currently have in place what we call
sort of the fraud hotline um we would
anticipate just like with with any
entity that should be paying tax that is
not being pay that is not paying their
tax we do get those calls we would
assume these calls would come in in that
same manner identifying an organization
uh and we would uh look into as a part
of the duties of our audit division
would look into those um uh those
potential taxpayers and whether or not
they would need to start paying tax um
we would investigate that the same way
that we currently do with respect to all
taxpayers thank you and follow would you
need on some kind of guidance as
to the NGO in
question had uh
had dealt with one case or uh for a long
time or just dealt with with one case
over a
weekend uh that was an illegal
migrant
um on would would you ha have to go
into uh removing their tax status in New
Hampshire or
um would you would you be required to do
that if we didn't have any kind of
limits on this thing so the bill
provides a definition at
U
on lines um 19 through the beginning of
the top of the next page provides a
definition of what uh constitutes I'm
sorry starting at line
25 and going on um it's provides a
definition of what constitutes settling
and resettling um and that is the
criteria that we would utilize in
analyzing whether someone needed to
begin paying
tax you follow
up so that would mean
if an
organization which was in general doing
charitable work in the state and had one
case of somebody that they hadn't
realized was an illegal immigrant or
that they had realized was an illegal
immigrant that also got help uh would
have their tax status removed
potentially yes the bill doesn't talk
about substantially or materially it
just simply defines what it would mean
to do the kind of work that would mean
an entity needed to be subject to the
business Enterprise
tax thank
you no
that okay represent ORS thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
so are the revenue estimates for the
upcoming year above plan or below plan
so the revenue estimates for the
upcoming year um there's has not been a
plan established with respect to the the
future years but if you're talking about
how we're doing for the remainder of the
current fiscal year we are coming in
below plan below plan so with taxing
these organizations help that deficit um
well I think the effective date of this
would be after the um upcoming fiscal
year but uh this could potentially be a
revenue increasing measure follow up so
would you uh are you willing to look
into the fact whether or not the these
organizations should be taxed and get
back to us I'm not sure what you mean by
I'm asking you to to check into this
this representative I don't I don't
think they they're not gonna they can't
determine whether there's taxation this
bill is it's a policy thing thank you
yeah done okay uh any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you okay is there anyone else who wishes
to testify who has not
testified seeing none I'm going to close
the hearing on HB
635 be careful my phone is right there
I think uh this is this is one bill that
we will or one of the bills that we'll
have probably have a work session on to
come to a conclusion so that that
concludes our work for this week uh next
week we are scheduled for Monday Tuesday
and Wednesday again um but um and it's
the the F it's TVD but the following
week we may only meet one day we may
only meet on Wednesday that has not been
determined yet but it at most it would
be two days not next week so next week
is three days the following week is
either one or two days the following
week which is the vacation week I'm not
going to schedule anything there's no
house session scheduled I won't schedule
any committee meeting so you'll have
that complete vacation week off which
whatever it's the last week in February
following into first couple days in
March
UMES did you have something you wanted
to say yeah on this is one of the early
bills so we have to figure out when work
session well do we already have it um we
have it scheduled I think for exec
um yeah if I'm not mistaken um in bills
that are complex and this then the
language on this one is a little murky
it's a lot murky but it has some Merit
to be
examined one of the ways we can handle
that is to retain the
bill uh so that when we have a little
more after we got all the revenues done
and all that stuff and depending upon
how many Senate bills we can work on it
a little bit uh through the rest of the
uh winter and spring and then we can do
it again in the fall to report out in
November uh it's it's to be up to the
chair and and to the ranking member as
to what they want to do
but I'm trying to find the the email
that I sent that
let's I just want to verify that is on
for next week
um next Tuesday okay yeah thank you
starting at two o'clock we're executing
four bills next two well I had to put in
a time uh we may not get to it till 3
o'clock um we are doing um Revenue
estimates all day
Tuesday we're going to hear from Dr on
Monday uh Monday morning probably 10 to
12 Dr is going to give us their revenue
estimates and those estimates account
for about 70% of the
total for for the state for the for over
the bium so that's extremely important
in the afternoon on February Monday
February 10th we'll have our first work
session on discussing where we think uh
how do how do we you know all the the
estimates that have come in from Dr the
other agencies how do we feel about it
and um and how would we potentially
modify it and then Tuesday and then
following on that Tuesday 10 to 12 and
and roughly 1 to two or one to three we
will continue to work on those estimates
and see how much progress we're making
um and I but I didn't want to schedule
the exact for three just in case we are
done a little earlier we can we can
start at two you can always start later
so I set it you'll see it at two it
could slide a little bit but uh we've
got four bills now one of those four
bills uh as Jennifer pointed out is
6:35 and
um at that point by then um I will
decide with help from others
um should we just execute or should we
combine a work session with the exe I
can't notice a work session anymore but
we that doesn't stop us from executing
it and talking about it if we feel like
we can come to some conclusion one way
or another um
or as Jordan pointed out I could um push
it off retain it and we can deal with it
later so try to get a consensus of where
we think we're at SC P want
wait oh that's not a bad idea maybe we
can do a straw pull now do to um what
would the straw pull be what's your
suggestion for the the straw ball and
retain would
be my suggestion would be to to give
this a good looking at uh and run it
through in retain um because there there
may be some things to it there I see
some areas that need to be examined a
little bit more deeply uh definitions
need to be
changed uh we essentially entail
rewriting the bill and we may come to
that conclusion very
rapidly um
but at the for the time being since it
has to be reported out by the 6th we
probably should be reported out as being
retained uh would be my suggestion and
well the choice I think the choices are
retained or itl I'm not sure how it's
OTP as it is without unless somebody
wants to bring a
uh no no March March 6th you're right
the February 6th is tomorrow that's a
good point
um so I mean I guess uh how do people
feel do people how many people think we
should retain it and then I'll ask how
many people think we should itl it uh
contain one two three four five six
seven eight how many feel feel like it
should be ited now one two three four
five
you went on the wrong one so one two
three four five six seven so now it's s
seven okay that
didn't that didn't work very well all
right sorry about that well we'll uh we
can make we can make that decision on
next
Tuesday
yeah yeah yeah
that's that's there
are all right we'll say that disc
for all right thank you everyone we're
all set for